Weiss nicht, hey! Ja, hey, ho, ho! Hey, hallo, wir grüssen euch ganz hässlich! Das hältst du jetzt die ganze Zeit in der Hand, oder was? Ich weiss nicht, ich dachte erst mal, ich zeige mir ein bisschen die Umgebung. Ja, herzlich willkommen zum YouTube-Ufo Nummer drei, live aus New York. Wir sind tatsächlich in New York und haben uns nicht in Köln irgendwo in den Wald gesetzt. Es sieht vielleicht ein bisschen so aus. Es sieht ein bisschen so aus, wir haben uns ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht. Hinten haben wir so Skyline. Vielleicht haben wir auch danach im Photoshop noch so ein bisschen Skyline reingearbeitet. Na, was heißt Skyline? Wir wollten euch ja mal so eine andere Seite von New York zeigen. Die Natur, ja, wir sind hier im Central Park und es ist herrlich, ein herrlicher sonniger Tag. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig billig, egal. Es hat so ein bisschen Blair Witch Feeling, habe ich das Gefühl. Also, falls das nicht gut ausgeht, ihr könnt schon die einzelnen Beweise zusammensammeln. Wenn das gleich umkippt dann, dann ist das ja vollkommen der Abspann. Naja, gut. Wir sind hier drin, wir sind hier direkt neben dem Baseballplatz. Wir lieben Baseball, das ist unser Sport. Wir sind nämlich mittlerweile völlig in Amerika angekommen, wir sind in New York, wir fühlen uns als New Yorker, wir sind da. Wir sind angekommen, ja, muss man sagen. Du hast heute schon, also Flo und und ich, wir sind heute Morgen relativ früh aufgestanden. Ich stand in der Küche schon und habe mir so ein Bagel-Spiegelei-Käse-Ding gemacht. Und dann kamst du raus und du warst nicht so glücklich wie sonst morgen. Du bist ja ein Morgenmensch, du bist ja glücklich. Ja. Heute kam er raus mit, ich glaube, ich habe Scheisse gebaut. Ich glaube, ich habe echt Scheisse gebaut. Was war passiert? Es ist, ich glaube, das klassische Sommerproblem, nennen wir es mal das Sommerproblem.
Man denkt sich, oh, es ist Sommer, es ist heiß, ich hau mal ein kühles Kältgetränk, das ist nicht kalt genug, ich hau es mal in den Gefrierschrank und dann irgendwann liegt man im Bett um drei Uhr nachts und denkt sich, fuck. Wie ist es um drei Uhr nachts aufgefallen? Und du hast noch nichts getan dagegen? Ich dachte mir, ja, also es ist im Gefrierfang, meine Glasflasche war gefroren.
Und man denkt sich ja um drei Uhr nacht, ja, jetzt kann ich eh nichts mehr ändern. So, das ist so wie Tschernobyl 20 Minuten nach der Explosion, man denkt sich, jetzt ist eh gelaufen, jetzt kann ich mich nochmal hinlegen. Jetzt sollten wir nicht irgendwie die Grafitblöcke einsammeln und versuchen, das Glück zu verhindern. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Jetzt erstmal ausschlafen. Wichtig ist auch, glaube ich, dass man in Zeiten der Krise schlafen kann. Ja, das ist das Allerwichtigste. Daran erkennt man einen erfahrenen, krisengeschärften Verstand, der sagt, oh, hier brennt's. Ich lege mich erst mal hin, um Kräfte zu sammeln. Was wird das jetzt? Ich lege mich hin, um Kräfte zu sammeln. Ich lege mich erst mal hin, ich mache es mir mal gemütlich,, hol mir mal... Okay, so läuft das hier nicht, Stefan.
Ist mal eine doofe Idee. Aber sonst ist mein Kopf immer so abgeschnitten.
Ja, und ja, auf jeden Fall heute Morgen hat es gefunktet, aber tatsächlich der Vorteil von diesen Verschlüssen, es ist kein richtiger Schraubverschluss, es ist nur so ein Klemmverschluss, dass der rausgedrückt werden kann durchs Eis und dann klappt der einfach ab und dann hast du wirklich so eine Eisfontäne, die so oben aus der Öffnung rauskommt. Wie so ein Kalippo. Genau, wie ein kleines Kalippo. Es war direkt lutschbereit, aber das war ganz, ganz nett eigentlich. Es ist nicht so viel passiert. Wobei mir ist schon oft eine Mate eingefroren mit einem Schraubverschluss, die hat so viel Kraft, dass der dann explodiert einfach direkt. Und man hört dann einfach mitten um drei Uhr noch so ein Bop und dann denkt man sich, war das jetzt ein Vogel, war das jetzt mal eine Mikrowelle, man weiss es nicht genau. Es ist so ein ganz eigenes Geräusch. Es ist auch kein so ein Knall, sondern so ein Baa und dann weiss man nicht genau. So ein Stöhnen, so ein Baa und Baa und man weiss halt nicht, ob das jetzt so schlimm ist. Weil oft, aber das habe ich gelernt, schlimme Dinge klingen oft nicht schlimm. Ja, ja.
Dinge, die wenig schlimm sind, klingen schlimm. Je schlimmer etwas klingt, desto weniger schlimm ist es. Das weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht genau. Doch wirklich, also zum Beispiel ist dir schon mal so eine Hart-Plastik-Flasche runtergefallen, so eine harte, so eine 1-Liter-Fanta-Flasche. Aber dieses harte Plastik, wenn das runterfällt, also wirklich, da ist der Einschürz eines Hochhauses nichts dagegen, das macht Geräusche aus den Niederhöllen. Und es passiert nichts. Das stimmt schon. Bam, bam, bam, durch das ganze Haus hört man es und es passiert rein gar nichts. Nee, nee, das stimmt schon. Wohingegen so ein Gasleck oder sowas. Wohingegen Achillessehne reisst, ist schlimm und ist ultralaut auch. Ja, na, weiss ich nicht. Es macht B, B, ich we weiss auch nicht genau, was du bekommst. Aber das muss ja auch ein Arzt wissen, wie Krankheiten klingen. Aber da sind wir tatsächlich bei einem sensorischen Feld, das ich ansprechen möchte, New York. Man kennt es aus Filmen, aber unglaublich auch, wie diese Stadt riecht. Ich weiss nicht, ob es daher kommt, dass einfach jeder Ort anders riecht und man sich an den Ort, wo man wohnt, gewöhnt hat einfach. Aber unglaublich, wie viele Gerüche und auch wie unglaublich es manchmal stinkt. Man hat ja in New York so, ja, irgendwie Better Call Saul, so richtig so Eindrücke Glamour. Better Call Saul, spielt nicht mehr in der Nähe von New York. Völlig falsche Referenz, ignorierst einfach. New Mexico. Und man hat da so ein bisschen Glamour Sinatra vor Augen, aber es stinkt wie die Hölle. Aber es hat so wirklich so, jeder Quadratmeter New York riecht anders. Ich glaube, man könnte so eine Wette... Und die auch mit Gerüchen, die man nicht kennt. Also aus anderen Gebieten der Welt, wo man nicht genau zuordnen kann. Immer so Gewürze, wo man nicht weiss, wie es da... Melasse zum Beispiel. Ich weiss nicht, wie Melasse riecht. Aber so manchmal sind so Gerüche am Start. Bergamotte, sowas, wo man auch immer so halb weiss, wie das riecht. Grob weiss, wo es herkommt. Der meiste Geruch eigentlich in New York ist heisser Müll. Also du hast ja diese Mülltüten, die überall rumliegen und die sind schwarz. Und wenn dann die heisse Sonne da drauf ballert, dann werden die erwärmt. Und das ist eigentlich das, was man meistens riecht, heisser Müll. Ist Hot Garbage, aber das ist so ein ganz eigener Geruch. In New York ist Hot Garbage. Ja. So, der fängt an zu köcheln und dann akkumuliert sich das so einen grossen Geruch. Gestern fing es auch an zu dampfen einfach, random, an Gegenden, wo ich war. Ja. Ich war gestern immer einfach so auf eigener Faust ein bisschen losgelaufen und war dann an Orten, wo man sagt, gut, wenn ich jetzt die falschen Sachen sage, bin ich tot. Und da waren auch so ein paar Orte einfach, wo dann plötzlich einfach einfach so ein Fffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffffff mal durch New York gelaufen ist und gesehen hat, oh, da kommt so Dampf aus den Gullideckeln raus, da sind bestimmt mutierte Ninja-Schildkröten drunter, die Pizza essen, und dann ist diese Idee ja überhaupt entstanden. Ja, kann sein. Genauso wie Shigeru Miyamoto, der Erfinder von Super Mario, der hat da auch in Tokio waren so Röhren, und dann dachte er sich, was ist in diesen Röhren drin, und die gibt es auch in Mario, diese grünen Röhren. Klempner, italienische Klempner, das ist auch im Kern das, was in diesen Röhren drin ist. Ja, ja, richtig. Aber wo wir gerade bei dummen Entscheidungen waren, du wolltest mich hier direkt ans Messer liefern mit meiner dummen Snapple-Idee im Gefrierfach. Wofür hast du heute noch mal 80 Dollar ausgegeben? Kannst du ganz kurz mal, also ich will jetzt nicht die alte Fehlkauftizetrope wieder aufmachen, aber vielleicht, ja, nee, aber vielleicht können wir einfach ein Kapitel noch mal neu angehen.
Einfach und ja, kannst du einfach mal sagen, wofür hast du heute? 80 Dollar, ja, also umgerechnet vielleicht so 50 Euro oder sowas. 500 Euro. Je nach Wechselkurs, wir wissen nicht, was passiert ist. Ich habe, muss man sagen, einen Zaubertrick gekauft. Weil, na ja, also man muss ein bisschen ausholen.
Wir sind seit drei Tagen jetzt hier.
Am ersten Tag kamen wir beide an und wir wollten uns nicht dem Jetlag ergeben und uns direkt schlafen legen, sondern wir wollten noch einen schönen, tollen, aufregenden Abend in New York haben. Ja, und deswegen haben wir beschlossen, komm, wir gehen in den Comedy Cellar, dem berühmten Comedy Club hier in New York und schauen uns First Class Comedy an.
Da gab es die Joke, New Joke Night, New Material Night, wo tolle, schon grosse Namen auch, wie zum Beispiel Michelle Wolff oder Todd Barry am Start waren und Material getestet haben und neue Jokes getestet haben. Und wir sassen in der ersten Reihe vorne auf so einem kleinen Sofa, dazu dann gleich später noch mehr. Aber es ist wirklich, man muss sagen, es war, die Show war darauf ausgelegt und jeder im Publikum wusste das, das sind unfertige neue Gags, also da kam dann jeder Comedian mit so einem Zettel auf die Bühne, wo dann einfach so drauf stand, die Gags, die haben die auch nicht auswendig gelernt, und haben dann wirklich immer wieder einen Gag gemacht, auf den Zettel geguckt, den nächsten Gag gemacht und dann war so teilweise kommentiert so, okay, der funktioniert gar nicht oder er braucht nur ein bisschen Arbeit, also wirklich so dieser Prozess. In Köln gibt es auch eine New Material Night, würde ich sagen. Das ist ganz spannend. Aber hier war es interessant zu sehen, manche haben, die nicht nur Gags getestet. Also die haben schon einen Bit. Zum Beispiel hat der Michelle Wolf ein grosses Männer sind scheisse Bit. Und hat dann einzelne Gags aus diesem Bit versucht. Und die haben teilweise nicht funktioniert, manche haben funktioniert. Und ihr ging es auch gar nicht darum, jetzt dieses Bit auszubauen, sondern einfach nur kleine Gags herauszufinden, die man irgendwann da einbaut. Das fand ich ganz spannend. Sie hat nicht versucht, das ganze Bit zu machen, immer nur diese kleinen einzelnen One-Liner und die hat sie getestet. Naja, jedenfalls war der Abend lang und da waren viele Comedians, so um die zehn, würde ich mal sagen, und einer davon war sehr overdressed, hat er auch kommentiert, weil er danach noch zu einer Comedy-Show musste, zu einer Zauber-Show musste, zu einer Magie-Show. Und dann hieß es ja, er macht schon seit längerem, seit er sechs ist oder so, zaubert er ganz gerne mal nebenbei. Und dann hat der Host ihn nochmal auf die Bühne geholt und hat gesagt, komm, wir machen einen Trick. Und zwar mit den beiden Deutschen, die vorne in der ersten Reihe sitzen natürlich. Und dann war Florentin Opfer, wie ich es nenne. Also im Amerikanischen würde ich sagen Volunteers. Ich sage immer Opfer dazu, weil es immer unangenehm ist. Dieses Zaubertricks. Und der Trick bestand darin, dass man dir ein Handy gab und du hast Wikipedia aufgerufen.
Und dann hat der Zauberer die aufgefordert dazu, einen beliebigen Wikipedia-Artikel aufzurufen, den du dir komplett selber ausdenken kannst, in jegliche identische Richtung. Er muss halt ein paar mehr Absätze haben. Und du hast den Wikipedia-Artikel von Birne. Richtig. Das kam dir sofort im Kopf. So, das kam sofort, ja, weil ich bin ja ein grosser Fan der Wikipedia und tatsächlich, kleiner Funfact im Rande, Birne war der erste Artikel in der Wikipedia, in der deutschen Wikipedia, glaube ich. Na spannend. Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es so Birne, sofort Birne gewikipediat und das ist übrigens eine grosse Kritik an Wikipedias, die haben kein smoothes Verb. Du kannst nicht skypen, googlen, du kannst nicht Wikipedia an. Geht nicht. Nachschlagen. Naja. Genau, du hast Birne und dann war die Aufgabe darin, dass du dir ein Wort aus diesem Artikel suchst, was Papa immer Silben hat, ein komplizierteres Wort und dir das merkt. Und dann hat er zwei Zettel geschrieben und hat die nacheinander umgedreht. Und er hat richtig erraten, welchen Artikel ich gelesen habe und welches Wort aus dem Artikel ich mir ausgut habe. Unglaublich. Und wir waren, das Publikum war baffled, wir waren baffled und ich, wir waren bambusel, baffled, wir wussten nicht mehr, was wir machen konnten. Ich habe die letzten beiden Nächte nicht geschlafen mehr, weil ich einfach über diesen Trickgedanken gemacht habe. Und man kann ja, und das wusste ich schon länger, seitdem ich ein grosser Pan-and-Teller-Fan bin. Okay, aber stopp, jetzt muss ich dich ganz kurz anhalten, weil es könnte sein, dass wir jetzt Probleme mit der Zauberer-Gilde bekommen, wenn du jetzt diesen Satz vollendest. Bist du dir sicher, dass du den Wut, den gebündelten Wut von mehr als hunderttausend Zauberern auf der ganzen Welt aufrichtest? Das Interessante ist, wenn die sind abgelenkt, weil der Magier mit der Maske ist ja immer noch nicht, niemand weiß, wer es ist. Das stimmt, den hat noch niemand gefasst, ja. Alle sind immer noch super wütend auf den, jetzt ist dem doch egal, dass ich hier im Central Park so ein bisschen ein paar Informationen aufschau. Ich möchte mich davon auf jeden Fall distanzieren. Okay. Alles, was jetzt kommt, ist allein der Inhalt von Stefan Michael Tietze, Adresse, 44 Street. Okay, tu es.
Also, ich habe den Trick gekauft.
Denn darum geht es ja. Man kauft sich als Magier, also die meisten Magier denken sich keine Tricks aus, die kaufen die zusammen, die kaufen sich, erkaufen sie ein Set. Das macht diese Kunstform wahnsinnig unsympathisch, wie ich finde. Weil du ja zu keinem Zeitpunkt selber, also die, klar überlegen die sich dann oft irgendwie den Rahmen, in dem sie einen Trick einbetten und so weiter, aber im Prinzip kaufen die die einfach nur. Und wenige mag ja, ich bin so fünf Prozent, die denken sich die Tricks aus und die verdienen auch viel Geld damit, vor allem weniger über Shows und vor allem über die Trickverkäufe. Und diesen Trick konnte man kaufen. Und ich dachte mir einfach, come fuck it, 80 Euro hat er gekostet. Und wir haben den, muss man sagen, einvernehmlich und zusammen haben wir uns entschieden, den zu kaufen. Nochmal Dank an alle Patreon-Spender hier an der Stelle. Vielen Dank. Ihr wisst mittlerweile, euer Geld ist in guten Händen. Genau. Wir haben jetzt für euch gekauft den Trick, wir werden ihn euch aber nicht verraten, weil wir wollen euch den Spaß auch nicht verderben. Aber ich bin jetzt wahnsinnig erleichtert und natürlich wahnsinnig enttäuscht, weil die Wirkung immer cooler ist als der Trick an sich. Aber es hat trotzdem grossen Spaß gemacht, auch wenn die Tricks gekauft sind. Ich meine, es ist ja eigentlich egal, wo die herkommen. Ich meine, du musst es ja auch performen. Ich meine, es ist ja alles Performance und das ist ja nicht so leicht. Der Abend war jedenfalls ganz schön denkwürdig. Es fing an, wir kamen da an und dann waren wir, ja, war seid ihr zu zweit, jo, er wollte ganz vorne sitzen und ich hätte, ich habe die Frage nicht mitbekommen, nur per fair, wenn ich die Frage mitbekommen hätte, hätte ich laut gerufen, nein, nein, ich habe es nicht mitbekommen. Stefan hat Angst, dann irgendwie mal auf die Bühne gezogen zu werden. Und Flo hat sofort gesagt, schur, schur. Und Cut zwei Minuten nach der Vorführung.
Ja, du hattest recht, wir hätten uns niemals in die erste Reihe setzen sollen, weil natürlich an so einer scheiss Weeknight, mitten in der Woche, sitzen da zwei Deutsche im Publikum, in der ersten Reihe auf so einem Sofa, viel zu eng, der eine hat ein Toast Shirt an und ein Short, der den Schritt minimal verdeckt, der andere ist unfassbar müde und gähnt die ganze Zeit, weil er gerade acht Stunden her geflogen ist usw. Das heisst, wir waren wahnsinnig müde beide, waren beide unangepasst aus und sassen dann halt auf so einem scheiss Couch da vorne in der ersten Reihe. Und jeder Comedian hat sich übrigens lustig gemacht. Ja, es stimmt. Meine Denkweise war die, beim Comedy-Seller weiss man nie, wer auftritt. Es gibt zwar ein Line-Up, aber es kann ja auch immer wieder ein bisschen reinstreuen.
Da kann Demetri Martin auftauchen oder Pete Davidson oder man weiss es ja nie. Sarah Silverman kann da vorbeikommen. Da dachte ich mir, ich habe ja schon mal Pete Holmes gehigh-fived. Und das geht ja nur, wenn man vorne sitzt. Und das war der schönste Moment meines Lebens und der stolste Moment meines Lebens, als ich Pete Holmes gehigh-fived habe. Dann dachte ich, ich sitze wieder vorne, damit, falls wieder jemanden kommt, den ich gerne mag, den ich in mein Herz geschlossen habe, dass ich den wieder high-fiven kann. Obwohl es vielleicht ich selber gar nicht so cool fände, wenn ich Pete Holmes wäre. Kann man auch mal drüber reden. Also Pete Holmes, falls du zuhörst, melde dich. So und deswegen dachte ich, ich setze mich in die erste Reihe und ja, hat nicht funktioniert, ist dann nach hinten losgegangen und Der Host ist ein bisschen geschwommen zwischen den Acts und hat sich immer wieder über die Deutschen lustig gemacht.
Und hat sich immer wieder darüber lustig gemacht, dass ich Birkenstocks anhatte und kurze Hose.
Aber gut. Ich habe dir auch schon tausendmal gesagt, dass das vielleicht nicht richtig ist.
Ja, es ist heiß, es ist heiß. Da träge ich gerne Birkenstocks. Füsse müssen atmen.
Haben wir nichts von Georgs gelernt eigentlich.
Aber Georgs ist auch nicht mehr der Schuh, der atmet. Die haben sich langfristig davon gelöst. Der Schuh, der jetzt auch aufgehört, ist zu atmen. Frankfurt, der Flughafen haben wir einen Georgs-Laden gefunden. Nirgendwo kam das Verb atmen vor. Nirgendwo. Im ganzen Laden nicht. Nee, das ist irgendwie, ja, dem Verlernen zu atmen, vielleicht einfach, vergessen zu atmen. Ich weiss nicht, ob Georg Schuh noch atmen, aber das könnt ihr mal rausfinden, das ist vielleicht ein ...
Können wir ein paar Mails schreiben.
Dankeschön übrigens für die ganzen Mails für Julias Gewinnspiel.
Floridin, ich kenne das ja nicht immer so mit, was auf der Mailadresse passiert.
Ich glaube, unser Server ist mir immer zusammengebrochen. Vielen Dank für die ganzen Mails. No, we just went that way, there is a gate. seit einer Woche beendet wurde, kriegen wir immer noch täglich Nachrichten. Ja, es ist vorbei. Auf jedem erdenklichen Weg. Ich habe private Nachrichten auf meinem Instagram-Account bekommen von Leuten, die gesagt haben, ich hätte gerne ein Buch. Also ich finde, es ist so interessant, weil die Leute wollen ein Buch gewinnen, können aber nicht lesen, wie sie dieses Buch gewinnen. Das ist ja schon irgendwo ein Disconnect, wo man sagt, ich würde gerne das Buch gewinnen, können aber nicht lesen, wie sie dieses Buch gewinnen. Das ist ja schon irgendwo ein
Disconnect, wo man sagt, ich würde gerne das Buch gewinnen. Mal schauen, wie kann ich es denn gewinnen?
Aber ich will es nicht so sehr gewinnen, dass ich mich damit auseinandersetzen will, wie man es gewinnt.
Die Leute wollen das Buch gewinnen und dann kommt die Frage, wie kann ich denn teilnehmen?
Und anstatt dass sie recherchieren und sich diese Frage selber antworten, geben sie einfach selber eine willkürliche Antwort drauf und sagen, ja, ich schreibe jetzt random hier irgendwie an die Facebook-Seite, an Twitter, aber ist okay, ist alles angekommen, kein Problem. Aber natürlich die Gewinner, ihr hört wahrscheinlich auch gerade zu, wir müssen euch leider vertrösten, wir können die Bücher erst nach unserem Urlaub verschicken, weil ich hab's versaut, gebe ich ganz ehrlich zu, ich hab's verbockt und die kommen aber auf jeden Fall zu euch und da habt ihr eine schöne, schöne Sommerlektüre. Das ist was Besonderes, weil diese Folge wird auch als normaler Podcast veröffentlicht werden, also müssen wir euch vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen reinholen. Wir sitzen gerade, was ihr nicht seht, wir sitzen mitten im Central Park und hier ist ein grosses, haben wir auch gerade schon gesagt, ein grosses Baseballfeld. Wir sehen dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal kein Baseball. Wir haben uns diesmal auf Shows konzentriert.
Wir haben Musicals, drei Musicals, zwei Theaterstücke, drei Comedy-Shows. Unglaublich. Wir geben alles. Ja, wir geben alles. Wir waren gestern in einem ganz neuen Musical, Hadestown hat das. Die hat bei den Tony Awards alles abgeräumt. Das ist quasi der wichtigste Musicalpreis. Ganz spannend, es ging um die mehr oder weniger lose, um die Sage um Orpheus und Riedeke und er hat daraus so folkmässig, bluesmässige Musik gemacht, alles sehr abstrakt, sehr metaphorisch, nicht so on the nose, wie man das von den ganzen Musicals kennt, die es nach Deutschland schaffen da meistens. Ja. Ich fand das sehr, sehr interessant und sehr cool. Und was hier im Broadway halt auffällt, also die Choreografien sind halt on point, die Bühnenbilder sind halt on point, die Sänger sind unglaublich gut, du hast wahnsinnig solle Livemusik. Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie man Musicals fertig machen kann. Die haben alle so eine Power und die haben so viel Bock und jeder einzelne, du kannst ja, da gab es dann so einen Chor von fünf Leuten und jeder einzelne performt on point perfekt. Wirklich, das Gesicht ist perfekt, die Schauspielerei ist perfekt, das ist alles perfekt, es ist wirklich fantastisch. Körper sind perfekt. Es ist wirklich fantastisch. Aussehend, das ist grossartig. Man will mittanzen. Man will direkt mittanzen. Du hast auch ein paar mittanzen. Ich habe ein bisschen mitgetanzt, ja. Da muss ich oft sagen, komm zurück. Das Spannende ist, das ist eine lustige Insidergeschichte, aber wir sind nur an die Karten gekommen, weil das Management, was uns managt, auch lustigerweise seit Jahren diese Sängerin managt, die das Musical created hat. Ja. Und die ist eine Britin und dieses Stück ist wohl über Jahrzehnte, zehn Jahre entstanden. Ein Jahrzehnt, genau. Aber das klingt weniger als es ist. Zehn Jahre lang hat das gebraucht. Es war damals ein Konzeptalbum, die ist eine Sängerin, hat die ganze Zeit das Album rausgebracht und hat immer schon die Idee gehabt, das mal in ein Stück umzumünzen.
Und das ist wohl ähnlich, wenn man das auch bei Filmen mitbekommt oder die Erfahrung, die ich bei der Serie gemacht habe jetzt.
Du hast halt einfach sehr viel Zeit, brauchst du das zu entwickeln.
Und dann war es jahrelang ein Off-Broadway-Stück, dann irgendwann kommen Produzenten ins Spiel, die finden das dann toll, dann kommen Caster ins Spiel und andere Geldgeber, Regisseure, Bühnenbildner und so.
Und dann musst du halt gucken, dass du die richtigen Leute an der Hand hast und dann wird es halt wirklich zu einem sehr grossen, tollen, durchperfektionierten Stück.
Ja.
Und das hat jetzt wirklich alle Preise abgeräumt und ist wahnsinnig erfolgreich. Ich glaube, es wird so ein bisschen das nächste Hamilton. Hat zumindest Potential, finde ich. Ich würde auch so gerne Hamilton sehen. Ach ja. Moment, wir schauen ja auch noch Hamilton an. Leine, leine, leine. Aber was ich gut fand an dem Stück ist, und das ist oft mein Kritikpunkt an Stücken und Theaterstücken, war, wenige Figuren. Ich mag Geschichten mit wenigen Figuren. Immer bei mir ist oft, wenn zu viele Figuren sind, steige ich direkt aus, direkt aus, zu viele und dann hast du noch drei Figuren und dann noch drei Offiziere und drei Edelleute und so, die alle dasselbe machen, furchtbar, aber da schön wenige Figuren, man konnte sich aufs Wesentliche konzentrieren und das finde ich dann auch genau richtig, so muss es sein. Und die kannte man ja auch schon, man kennt ja Hermes, man kennt ja Orpheus, man kennt Eurydice, man kennt Hades. Das waren sie alle, eigentlich die wichtigsten Leute. Ja, aber finde ich interessant, dass dieser uralte Stoff auch nochmal so neu aufgenommen wurde und dass man da auch irgendwie, dass das amerikanische Publikum da anscheinend auch Bock drauf hat, irgendwie so dann diese ganzen alten Sachen nochmal aufzuziehen. Ja. Aber gut funktioniert.. Also wenn ihr New York soll, auf jeden Fall dieses Musical anschauen. Ja, es ist so ein bisschen, ich glaube, wir sind momentan noch vor dem Hype. Vielleicht kommt der grosse Hype noch, vielleicht auch nicht. Das ist immer das Gefühl, wenn man sieht, was bald es schaffen wird. Ich bin mir da sicher, okay, der ist Flemmer da. Aber das ist noch dieses Eis-Stückkindringen beim Snapple, ne? Ja, das ist die Snapple, die komplett durchgefroren war. Und jetzt hatte ich diesen Eiskern, diesen Eisberg. Aber eigentlich perfekt. Das ist fantastisch. Das ist absolut perfekt. Aber mach's nicht noch mal. Heute Nacht. Bitte nicht noch mal. Ich will nicht aufwachen von so einem... Es ist tatsächlich interessant, Stefan und ich, wir kennen uns jetzt schon lange, aber man lernt sich wirklich erst mal kennen, wenn man zu zweit in einer Wohnung wohnt. Aber warum haben wir auch schon mehrere Male getan? Florentin, dein Snapple tropft jetzt gerade in den Kühlschrank. Ich sag's dir nur, ich sag's dir nur mal. Da merkt man einfach, okay, gut, mit welchem Menschen da man eigentlich schon seit Jahren zusammenarbeitet. Wird einem dann erst klar? Nee, du sagst halt, also es ging um den Snapple, den hast du dann nämlich zum Schmelzen, also der war gefroren, du hast ihn zum Schmelzen, hast du ihn reingelegt in den Kühlschrank. Und ich habe den Kühlschrank aufgemacht und sah nur, wie der Snapple, ich sag mal, so vulkanartig ausläuft und langsam schmilzt in den Kühlschrank hinein und der Kühlschrank so eine braune Pfütze schon hatte. Und dann habe ich dir gesagt, du satt seelendurch auf der Couch, hast gegessen und irgendeinen YouTube-Scheiss geschaut und dann habe ich dir gesagt, der Snapple läuft über. Und du hast gesagt, ja gut, keine Reaktion. Wo ich dann auch dachte, okay, mit so einem Menschen machst du seit Jahren ein Podcast.
Ja, ja.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja, jetzt gerade läuft er über, Florian. Also, in diesem Moment. Und du hast mir über Schwerkraft erzählt.
Ja, aber die Schwerkraft ...
Er versucht mich herauszureden.
Ja.
Hat auch kurz kurz ...
Nein, da ist kein Fleck.
Nein.
Deine Ausrede war, es liegt an der Schwerkraft. Ich hab gesagt, ja, aber das ändert ja nicht, das Spiel schon gerade dreckig wie. Naja, aber das ist ja so, du darfst ja nicht sauber machen, während der Verschmutzungsprozess noch in Gange ist. Du musst den Verschmutzungsprozess abwarten und wenn er beendet ist, dann kannst du sauber machen. Nein, das ist halt genau der Fehler, das ist der Denkfehler. Nein, das ist genau der richtige. Nein, du hättest einfach die Kinder rausnehmen können, ganz kurz abtrinken können, was dann übergelaufen ist und wieder reinstellen können. Ja, aber dann tropft sie wieder weiter. Nein, es tropft nicht weiter. Das ist ja genau, da war ja nicht viel, viel zu viel Eis oben drauf. Na ja, gut. Das ist prima privat war da dieses Gespräch. Das wird übrigens wahrscheinlich auch in das YouTube-UFO-Folge 2 geteilt, weil wir haben so ein bisschen Akku-Probleme. Wir sind hier unterwegs und haben, glaube ich, nicht genug Akku, eine komplette Folge aufzunehmen. Das heißt, es könnte sein, dass wir uns später noch auf dem Dach von unserer Wohnung befinden werden, wenn wir den zweiten Teil aufnehmen. Mal schauen, wie lange unser Akku durchhält. Tatsächlich mein Laptop gibt komplett auf. Und es ist entscheidend, weil die Laptops, also die Macbooks haben unten ja so vier Gumminoppen, die dann so ein bisschen Abstand machen und rutschfest. Und bei mir haben die sich alle jetzt im Laufe der Zeit verabschiedet. Und das ist interessant, weil ich habe den zwei Jahre lang und dann haut der erste Gumminoppel ab und innerhalb von wenigen Tagen. Wo ist er hin jetzt? Ich weiss es bis heute nicht. Hat einen Krebsstand aufgemacht. An der Nordsee. In Palermo oder so. Ich weiss nicht genau. Der erste Gumminoppel verabschiedet sich und innerhalb kürzester Zeit sind die anderen auch weg. Also das ist wirklich so, wenn dann mal der Damm gebrochen ist, dann hauen alle ab. Und dadurch lag mein Laptop immer nicht erhöht, sondern lag immer direkt auf der Oberfläche und dadurch ist er ständig überhitzt und dadurch ist jetzt wirklich mein Akku einfach kaputt. Ja, das kann gut sein. Und hey, und da steht auch irgendwie Akku kaputt, bitte unbedingt dringend auswechseln und so, aber ja. Bei mir ist alles in Ordnung, trotzdem hält er maximal, also maximal eine Stunde. Und wenn du Dinge machst, gar nicht. 20 Minuten. Ja, das ist echt ungemütlich.
Ist es auch. Ja, vertritt dir mal ein bisschen die Beine. Man muss auch sagen, also ich bin gestern so viel rumgelatscht, das ist wirklich, die Entfernungen hier sind doch einfach auch ungewohnt. Und ich muss sagen, U-Bahn ist nicht so mein Ding und deswegen gehe ich dann lieber mal ein paar Meter. Und das war wirklich gestern sehr anstrengend, aber man isst hier so viel Quatsch, dass man sich auch ein bisschen häufiger die Beine vertreten sollte. Aber so leckeren Quatsch, so leckeren Quatsch. Allein die Cornflakes ist unglaublich. Ich meine, Kellogg war doch ein Deutscher, oder? Dieter Kellogg, der, ich weiss nicht, warum es sich immer so entwickelt, dass Amerika alles übernimmt und geiler macht und in Deutschland wir einfach hinterher hinken. Die Fruit Loops, die deutschen Fruit Loops sind einfach eine Schande, wo du dann irgendwann gesagt hast, ja, mit weniger Zucker, mit weniger Farbstoff und denkst dir, ja Leute, was bleibt denn da noch übrig? Das ist ja nichts mehr. Und hier in Amerika hast du einfach die Fruit Loops, die sind noch in your face süss, da schmeckt jedes, jede einzelne Farbe schmeckt nach einem anderen radioaktiven Element, aber es schmeckt einfach so geil, es kommt einfach alles zusammen. Und du hast gesagt, warum kaufst du denn hier Fruit Loops, gibt es aber in Deutschland. Es ist ein Riesenunterschied, es ist ein Riesenunterschied. Jeder, der die deutschen Fruit Loops mag, wird von den amerikanischen Fruit Loops dahingeschmolzen werden. Ja, boah, das ist wahnsinnig unbequem. Wahnsinn. Aber man muss sagen, Apple Jacks hat mich wahnsinnig enttäuscht, Apple Jacks ist ja die Idee, Zimt und Apfel zu kombinieren. Du hast direkt bessere Apple Jacks gefunden, ne? Ich habe aus Versehen in den Schrank gegriffen und habe bessere Apple Jacks gefunden, nämlich so Cinnamon Toasts, Cinnamon Apple Toasts. Das sind so kleine Toast-förmige Cornflakes, die sehen ein bisschen aus wie Katzenstreu, die sind immer wahnsinnig lecker, also wahnsinnig nicht schön. Und da muss Apple Jacks halt einfach den visuellen Vorteil, muss man schon auch sagen. Aber ich habe auch generell gut gegessen. Ich war gestern auf Anraten eines Freundes, der aus Chicago kommt. New York, New York, Geheimtipp. Und der hat lange hier auch in New York gelebt und der hat mir von Faicos erzählt. Faicos ist ein italienischer Spezialitätsupermarkt, so ein ganz kleiner Laden im East Village, den man gar nicht, da hat man nichts. Aber es ist ein uralter Laden, der war so 1907 oder so gegründet, eigentlich tausende Jahre alt. Und das ist ein Laden, da kommst du rein und du hast recht, das ist so eine frische Theke und das sind einfach diese grossen Blöcke Prosciutto und Mozzarella und Gorgonzola. Aber das sind so Bälle, ne? Also grosse Schinkenbälle, aber auch grosse Mozzarella-Bälle. Aber warum sind das immer Bälle, das verstehe ich nicht. Ich weiss nicht, aber es ist toll, so grosse Kugeln. Meine Käse sind aber auch rund und so, diese runden normalen, die man kennt. Und dann kann man dann da auch Sandwiches bestellen, was man gar nicht denkt. Die meisten Kau kommen da hin und bestellen sich einfach Schinken. Dann war eine Frau mit einem Hund, dann hat der Hund Schinken bekommen, das war alles seltsam. Jedenfalls steht dann in der Ecke, wenn man das nicht weiss, hätte ich das nie bestellt da, steht da so ein kleines Schild, The Italian Special, 18 Dollar. Und dann kann man für 18 Dollar dann Sandwich bestellen. Ich dachte mir, okay, ist das wert, 18 Dollar? Aber dann kriegst du wirklich das beste Sandwich weltweit. Okay, das ist meine Ansage. Zumindest mal das beste Sandwich aus New York.
But if you make it here, you make it everywhere, auch als Sandwich. Und dann
holen die aus der Ecke so ein normale Subway-artiges Italian-Sandwich-Brot, was man kennt, und legen das dann unter so eine Maschine und dann holen die dann nach und nach, das dauert wirklich dann 15 Minuten, holen die dann verschiedene Bälle, Schinken, legen die in diese Maschine und dann kurbeln die und der schneidet dann so ganz hauchdünne Scheiben auf das Sandwich. Und das ist dann Kochschinken, Rohrschinken, dann machen die das Gleiche mit Mozzarella, verschiedene Mozzarella-Sorten, dann kommen Tomaten drauf oben noch, Salzalat drauf und dann so eine geile Tomatensauce und dann kriegst du das und dann wird das dort ganz so eingerollt, das hält gar nicht zusammen, weil das so dick ist. Dann wird das eingerollt in Papier und dann kommt er mit so einem grossen Messer und schneidet das Einwandermitt durch und dann kriegst du das und das ist wirklich jeden Cent wert. Das war fantastisch lecker. Das scheint aber auch so ein amerikanisches Grundverständnis zu sein, dass einfach viel einfach geil ist. So in Deutschland kann man sich das gar nicht vorstellen, es gibt ja auch so dieses legendäre Sandwich bei Katz Delikatessen, irgendwas auch so ein uraltes Ding. Was aber auch einfach zehn Zentimeter langer Pastrami ist. Ja, du hast eine Scheibe Brot, zehn Zentimeter Pastrami, Scheibe Brot obendrauf. In Deutschland würde man dich verachten dafür, aber hier einfach, und es ist einfach geil. Es ist einfach all in. Du denkst einfach über Generationen, hat jede Generation noch eine Scheibe obendrauf gelegt. Das ist auch diese Form des Selbstbewusstseins, was was es hier einfach gibt. Ich muss mal auch wieder sagen, ich bin in New York immer wahnsinnig eingeschüchtert von den Leuten. Aber alle so cool sind. Weil alle wirken wahnsinnig cool und selbstbewusst. Und man selber denkt immer, ja. Ich meine, wir sind ja wieder in Williamsburg, das ist ja dieser klassische Hipster-Viertel in New York, in Brooklyn. Und da passt natürlich Stefan Tietze super rein. Du hast ja auch schon Kleidung gekauft, du hast schon Brillen angeguckt und so, aber das ist schon wirklich, da wird man da schon überschwemmt von Coolness.
Jeder kommt dir entgegen und du denkst, alter, der hat mindestens drei Podcasts, der ist richtig cool.
Und der hatte diese Woche schon Sex.
Ja, und es ist unglaublich, jeder ist cool, jeder hat Tattoos und ich lasse mich wahnsinnig krass beeinflussen davon, ich weiss gar nicht warum.
Ich glaube, das ist immer noch so ein aus der Schule kommendes Fakt, der ist cool, ich muss mich unterordnen.
Es ist immer noch so, ich habe einfach Respekt vor solchen Leuten, die irgendwie dann so ein cooles mit so einem fetzigen politischen Spruch auf dem T-Shirt nehmen. So wow! Ich weiss gar nicht warum. Und die hören auch alle Musik, also die laut. Ja. Also die haben so viel Selbstbewusstsein hätte ich nie, dass du in der U-Bahn einfach mal für die ganze U-Bahn ein Lied anmachst, also so eine Bluetooth-Speaker. Und alle finden es auch ganz gut, weil dann lieber das als die U-Bahn-Geräusche zu hören und dann macht sie einfach da so einen Hip-Hop-Song an. Ich hätte nie in meinem Leben mein Selbstbewusstsein, meinen Song, den ich gerade höre, für alle in der U-Bahn zu entscheiden, was wir jetzt hören. Und was man auch oft sieht und was mich überrascht hat und was auch Stefan Tietze für mich wieder in ein anderes Licht gerückt, Boosterboards. Sehr viele Boosterboards sieht man häufig und das hat sich hier nicht durchgesetzt, aber ein paar... New York ist aber auch keine Boosterboardstadt. New York ist nicht dafür gemacht. Du hast wenig, also hier im Central Park kann man das machen, aber es ist auch natürlich verboten, mit solchen Gefährten hier rumzufahren. Aber ansonsten hast du ja in New York keine Wege, du hast ja kaum Radmöglichkeiten. Muss aber das ja eigentlich San Francisco zu Hause. Naja, okay. Ja, klar. Ich habe ja auch so unangenehme Situationen, weil obwohl man mit Englisch ja gut klarkommt, ich habe das letzte Jahr auch viel auf Englisch gearbeitet, aber es ist einfach dann doch manchmal noch eine andere Sprache. Und ich glaube, wir sprechen so gut Englisch, dass die Leute mittlerweile nicht sofort merken, dass sie woanders herkommen. Und deswegen ballern die einfach ein, die nehmen keine Rücksicht und reden nicht langsam oder sowas. Das macht es aber nicht einfacher. Eigentlich müsste man Deutscher reden, als man es normalerweise macht. Ich glaube, Werner Herzog ist ja nicht dumm, er spricht ja auch wahnsinnig gut Englisch, muss man sagen. Er spricht wahnsinnig gut Englisch, er hat einfach nur einen unfassbar starken Akzent.
Ich glaube, das ist die Idee.
Ich glaube, du musst so selbstbewusst sein, dass du einfach den Akzent nicht versuchst zu überspielen. Ja.
Wenn du sagst, hello, where do I find this so-and-so-Station. Can you tell me the direction to the tourist information bureau?
Yeah.
Every human is lost, even in its own hometown. neben dir, das war so ein Inder und der hat einfach mal knallhart so eine grosse ein Kilo Tüte Fertignudeln aufgemacht und hat die Nudeln gesnackt. Im Flugzeug? Im Flugzeug, einfach wirklich so ein Kilo-Ding und er hat die zermalmt in der Tüte und weggesnackt und ich dachte mir, okay, okay und dann dreht er sich zu mir, schüttelt mit der Hand und sagt so, ja, die Nudelhand, die Nudelhand und meint dann so, ja, hier, mein Name ist irgendwie Schamal oder irgendwie sowas und wir sitzen jetzt eh nebeneinander, können uns ja auch mal vorstellen. Waren Deutscher? Ne, waren Amerikaner. Und ich habe auch gesagt, ich habe auf Englisch geredet, er meinte so, ah, okay, you live in New York und ich so, ne, Cologne. Und meinte, ah, okay, gut, ja, und dann haben wir auch nicht weitergeredet. Also es war wirklich so ein Vorstellen. Zu Cologne fällt den meisten noch nichts mehr ein. Ne, das ist echt so ein Ding. Die meisten haben eine Berlin-Story, niemand hat eine Cologne-Story. Ja, ja, ja. Ja, aber das Unangenehmste im Englischen war wirklich gestern eine U-Bahn-Situation. Ich bin zunächst auf die falsche Seite, man hat ja diese Metro-Cards und dann, was genial ist, weil niemand kann schwarz fahren. Du kommst halt nur in die U-Bahn rein, wenn du mit der Metro-Card schon mal... Ja, ich sehe aber manchmal auch, dass die über diese Absperrungen rüberspringen.
Ja, gut, das sind dann wirklich... Schweres Krimine.
Die haben es dann aber auch verdient, finde ich.
Die haben es verdient, schwarz zu fahren, weil die so eine sportliche Höchstleistung auf sich genommen haben.
Ich bin jedenfalls auf der falschen Seite hoch und dann bin ich die Straßenseite, habe ich gewechselt und bin dann auf der anderen, auf der richtigen Straßenseite hochgegangen, zur U-Bahn-Station.
Und dann ging meine Karte aber nicht, weil die gesagt hat, you just used the card. Du benutzt die offensichtlich doppelt. Da könntest du ja auch einfach durchgehen, dem Freund die Karte geben und den auch noch durchlotsen. Deswegen ist da so ein gewisses Zeitlimit drin. Ich musste aber jetzt da rein, weil da eine Bahnkarte war und da bin ich zu so einer Frau in so einem Glaskasten gegangen und habe gesagt, excuse me, I just used the card, but I was on the wrong side. Und dann hatben gab es diesen Ausgang. Das ist einfach so ein, wie man das kennt, diese Türen, die sich drehen können. Diese Käse-Reiben-Dinger. Diese Käse-Reiben-Dinger. Also drei Möglichkeiten. Durch alle könnte man irgendwie, wenn die das freischaltet, durch. Ich dachte mir, fuck, schauen Sie jetzt 30, 33 Prozent, dass ich es richtig mache. Ich dachte mir, komm, gehe ich durch diese Drehdinger, wo man die Mitro-Karte benutzen kann, hat die bestimmt für mich freigeschaltet, diese Teile. Ich habe es versucht, nein. Da habe ich dann wieder die Stimme gehört, du du du du du du du du schon ein bisschen, sie sagt auch voll die Emotion kam durch, der Inhalt nicht. Aber die Em kamen so sehr durch, ja. The medium is the message. In dem Fall war dieses Mikrofon the message. Und dann dachte ich mir, fuck it, versuchte sie halt dieses Drehkreuz und sie hat gesagt, no, the door, the door, okay, the door. Sie war unter Wasser auch, der Plexiglasgasten hat voller Wasser. Sie lief langsam hoch. Jetzt war sie so ein bisschen, ich war in dem Escape Room, ich muss den richtigen Ausgang finden, sonst stirbt sie. Der schwerste Job in New York. Naja, dann habe ich die Tür und dann habe ich an der Tür gerüttelt und dachte mir, boah, jetzt geht die Tür auch nicht auf und sie hat gesagt, pull, nur pull, sir, pull. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, okay, I'm doing this. Ohne Mikrofon, pull, just pull, goddammit. Just fucking pull. Ja, dann habe ich gepullt und sie dachte auch, fucking idiot. Ich dachte selber, ich bin auch fucking idiot. Und das war sehr unangenehm. Ja. Weil für sie sah es so aus, als ob das einfach der grösste Depp ist, den es hier überhaupt jemals gab. Ja. Und eigentlich würde man eher darstellen wollen, dass man Deutscher ist, damit die sagen, okay, der ist halt einfach hier out of place.
Sie dachte einfach, ich bin so ein Williamsburger Hipster, der irgendwie durch Eltern an Geld gekommen ist.
Richtig, und jetzt mit der harten Realität der U-Bahn nicht zurechtkommt.
Und jetzt mit der harten Realität von Schildern nicht zurechtkommt.
Und der englischen Sprache. War sehr unangenehm, aber was soll's. Werbung. Gleich geht's weiter mit dem Podcast, wir erzählen euch ganz kurz was zur Dating-App LeVou, ja. Ja, Flo und Stefan erzählen euch jetzt mal, wie ihr am besten datet, denn da seid ihr bei uns an der richtigen Interesse. Nein, wir haben wirklich eine fantastische Überraschung für euch, denn wir haben für euch den Gutscheincode, mit dem ihr eine Woche lang LeVou Premium testen könnt. Moment, ohne was zu zahlen? Ja, ohne was zu zahlen. Und zwar, das ist die Definition von kostenlos. Und zwar mit try-live-now. Alles großgeschrieben, wobei ich nicht genau weiß, ob das wichtig ist, aber mit diesem Code könnt ihr alle Premium-Features nutzen, also das Premium-Modell von LeVou. Und generell hat LeVou ganz, ganz tolle Möglichkeiten, zum Beispiel den Live-Streaming-Dienst. Also man kann live streamen, wie man zum Beispiel auch Twitch streamen kann, und dann können Leute einem zugucken und sagen, Mensch, das ist ja ein lustiger Typ. Der ist gar nichts für mich. Den brauche ich gar nicht erst anschreiben, der brauche ich gar nicht meine Lebenszeit mit dem oder der verschwenden. Und das ist ja auch schon mal gut zu wissen. Das ist auch schon mal gut zu wissen. Generell erwartet euch bei LaVue eine grosse, tolle, lustige Community, wo ihr eure Kreativität freien Lauf lassen könnt. Locker einfach mal swipen am Wochenende. Gags raushauen, auf jeden Fall, Leute kennenlernen. Von daher, sucht den Code aus, testet den Code try-live-now und dann könnt ihr 168 Stunden, das habe ich gerade ausgerechnet, Premium-Features von LaVue testen.
Das könnt ihr ganz einfach in der App machen und die App findet ihr natürlich überall im Play- und App-Store oder auch einfach auf laVue.com.
Viel Spaß und viel Erfolg und vielleicht spricht man es auch LaVue aus, aber das kriegt ihr raus.
Steht auf einem anderen Blatt. Ciao.
Werbung. Wir sind hier im Central Park, wie gesagt. Wir haben hier die ganz schöne Natur um uns. Wir sehen die ganzen Leute hier durchlaufen. Central Park ist ja tatsächlich riesengross und ganz eckig, mitten in Manhattan. Und es gibt da auch so eine grosse Hauptstrasse durch und grosse Seen. Und es ist wie so ein kleineses Land und es hat so eine eigene Infrastruktur hier und es gibt überall kleine Strassen und Wege. Aber ich kann die Strassen nicht ernst nehmen, weil die Strassen gehen ja wie alle anderen Strassen auf der Welt auch so gebogen, wo man weiss, die Strasse hätte es nicht machen müssen. Der Knick ist unnötig, die Wege, die man geht, sind Quatsch. Jede Strasse, auf der auch jemand Inlandsgate fährt, kann ich nicht ernst nehmen. Das ist für mich keine echte Strasse. Nee, ich dachte jetzt eher an die, ich wollte in eine andere Richtung gehen, gedanklich. Alles klar, ich folge dir einfach mal. Wenn du jetzt auf einer schönen deutschen Strasse lang bist, Landstrasse, nimmst du Bögen, Kurven in Kauf. Du nimmst in Kauf, okay, ich gehe jetzt auf diesem gepflasterten Grund, dafür gehe ich auch mal eine Kurve, weil es halt um diesen, sagen wir mal, um so einen See herum muss oder um so ein Waldgebiet. Hier im Central Park hasse ich jede Kurve, die man gehen muss, weil jede Kurve ist by Design, jede Kurve ist ausgedacht, ist ein Designgrund, damit der Park den Anschein macht eines natürlichen Parks. Aber jeder Umweg, den man geht, ist eigentlich unnötig hier. War früher ganz New York so und die haben hier die Stadt drauf gebaut oder war früher
alles Stadt und die haben, also was war zuerst, der Park oder die Stadt?
Also war erst alles Park und dann hat man die Stadt außen herum gebaut?
Ist New York nicht einfach komplett am Reissbrett entstanden, mit dem Central Park als Idee
in der Mitte?
Ich meine, es war einfach von vornherein klar.
Aber mussten die dann hier Bäume pflanzen oder waren die schon hier und die haben die
einfach stehen gelassen?
Ach so. Weil eigentlich ist das hier eher so sumpflanzen oder waren die schon hier und die haben die einfach stehen gelassen?
Ach so. Weil eigentlich ist das hier eher so sumpfig. Wir sind ja auch... Haben die die Stadt um den Zinnepark herum gebaut? Man weiss es nicht genau. Wir sind auch angeflogen und dann der Anflug auf New York dauert dann irgendwie so 30 Minuten und man schaut aus dem Fenster und denkt sich, ah geil, gleich Empire State Building. Und dann schaust du runter und dann ist es irgendwie so ein Sumpfgebiet mit so Storchvögeln und dann denkst du ja, wo bin ich denn eigentlich? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo man da ist. Ich habe die Geografie nicht verstanden. Es war einfach ein grosser Sandstrand, so eine Sanddüne. Aber so ein wahnsinnig dünner, ganz langer Sandstrand. Das ist ganz merkwürdig. Und dahinter war lange wie so ein Wattland. Ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden. Es ist auch viel Klimaerwärmung, glaube ich. Das macht auch die Landschaft hier ein bisschen kaputt. Ja, aber ich habe wirklich generell keine Ahnung. Meine grösste Angst wäre, mit jemandem hierher zu fahren, der noch nie hier war und der mir fragt, ah, okay, und was ist das hier und ich immer so, keine Plan. Aber du warst doch schon mal hier. Du warst doch schon achtmal hier. Ja, ich war im Comedy-Seller und im Musical. Aber du hast doch gesagt, das ist dein Lieblingsteil der Stadt. Ja, ich habe trotzdem überhaupt gar keine Ahnung von gar nichts. Null. Das ist ein Problem. Da sehe ich im Supermarkt und ich liebe ja die Supermärkte hier, es ist so unglaublich, weil die Supermärkte sind so klein und gedrungen und wie so ein Labyrinth und teilweise es gibt in der Innenstadt Supermärkte, wo du reingehst und du denkst dir, das ist halt keine Ahnung, so ein kleiner Tante-Emma-Laden, aber dann gibt es noch so einen Weg nach hinten und dann gehst du nach hinten und dann sind ganz lange Regale und dann ist noch so eine Fleischtheke links und eine Käsetheke und du gehst nach rechts und plötzlich ist noch eine riesige Kränke und du denkst dir, wo kommt das alles her? Ja, wo kommen die Sachen mehr her? Und du hast so einen kleinen Dungeon und alles ist so gedrungen, was wir in Deutschland haben,
wir ja diese riesigen, freistehenden Aldi, Lidl, Edeka, Riesenteile, wo man einmal in der Woche hinfährt
und hier gibt es die gleiche Grösse, aber der Eingang ist irgendwo an der Strasse einfach so,
wo du dich ducken musst zum Reingehen und dann ist alles irgendwie unterirdisch
und da hat mich auch einer angesprochen. Smart oh so smart so smart smart police dann hat mich jemand angesprochen und meinte dann auch so excuse me can you help me und ich hatte schon das nein auf den Lippen einfach schon mal direkt einfach einfach so no Panik aufgerissen Augen und einfach aber der wollte dann nur, dass ich ihm was aus der aus der obersten Reghole. Habe ich natürlich auch gerne gemacht. Da dachte ich mir aber, gute Möglichkeit, um Brieftaschen zu klauen. Jemanden zu fragen, können Sie mir das geben, weil du streckst dich ganz aus, du verlierst dein Körpergefühl, weil du streckst dich ganz weit und du konzentrierst dich kriegst und währenddessen kann dir jemand ganz leicht das aus der Tasche nehmen. Und hat er gemacht? Nee. Aber ich dachte mir nur so, danke, dass du mir nicht meine, jetzt mein Geldbeutel geklaut ist, weil es wäre ohne weiteres möglich gewesen. Ja. Generell tatsächlich unsicherster Geldbeutel der Welt, mein Geldbeutel schaut auch immer so ein paar Zentimeter raus, ganz labbrige Jogginghose. So eine Lasche, wie man das kennt von diesen, wir hatten im Sportunterricht so Flatterbälle, so ein Tennisball mit so Flatterpapier hinten dran, den mussten wir werfen und so hast du das auch an dem Portemonnaie, so eine Klaulasche. Einfach so eine Schlaufe mit Pull hier, aber mir wurde noch nie der Geldbeutel geklaut. Mir wurde jetzt mein Fahrrad geklaut in König, das neue. Ach Gott, der Fahrrad. Aber es ist so lustig, also weil ich habe mir, habe ich ja erzählt, vor ein paar Wochen Fahrrad gekauft habe und es wurde geklaut. Und ich stand am Fenster, wollte gerade zum Sport und stand am Fenster mit gepackten Sachen und wollte das Fenster zumachen und sehe im Innenhof und des Hauses, es ist nicht da. Mein Fahrrad ist sehr leicht zu erkennen, weil es ganz gelb ist, es ist nicht da. Ich dachte, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, das kann nicht wahr sein. Da bin ich rausgerannt. Und tatsächlich, es war noch ein grosser Reifen da, mitten in meinem Schloss. Mein Schloss am Reifen und das Fahrrad war weg. Aber an dem Reifen klebt da eine Botschaft. Und zwar, ich dachte mir, jetzt schreibt da so ein Dieb, ich habe mir Fahrrad gekauft. Fuck you, fuck you, fuck you, you fucking fuck, dumb fuck. Nee, es war ein Zettel, so rausgerissen aus so einem karierten Notizheft, mit so einem Kabelbinder festgemacht. Da habe ich das Rad reingetragen, wo dann auch viele Nachbarn dachten, was ist sein Problem jetzt genau? Da habe ich das Rad hingestellt, durchgeschnitten in den Kabelbinder und diese Notiz gelesen und drin stand, ihr Fahrrad wurde bei einem Fahrraddiebstahl sichergestellt mit freundlichen Grüßen Polizei Köln.
Ach was, der wurde während dem Diebstahl gefangen?
Ich hatte keine Ahnung seit dem Zeitpunkt. Dann habe ich die Polizei angerufen, die wussten von gar nichts, rufen Sie morgen nochmal an.
Dann habe ich am nächsten Tag nochmal angerufen und dann haben die gesagt, dann habe ich beim Kriminalkommissarjad 55 in Köln angerufen und die wussten von gar nichts, rufen Sie morgen nochmal an. Dann habe ich am nächsten Tag nochmal angerufen. Und dann haben die gesagt, dann habe ich beim Kriminalkommissariert 55 in Köln angerufen und die wussten dann Bescheid. Und zwar wurde ein Typ gesehen von meinen Nachbarn, der hat sich komisch, ich nehme nebenan gibt es so eine Trinkhalle, so einen kleinen Kiosk, und da hat sich ein Typ wohl sehr, sehr komisch verhalten. Der wurde auch laut und rumgepöbelt, so ein bisschen so ein Drug Addict, so ein Junkie-Typ halt. Und dann haben die den beobachtet. Und dann ist er da so rumgeschlecht. Die Polizei oder die Häuser? Nee, die Nachbarn. Ah, okay. Und dann ist er so rumgelaufen und irgendwann hat er sich an den Fahrrad anzuschaffen gemacht. Dann haben sie nochmal geschaut, da war ein Fahrrad weg und er lief durch die Strasse mit so einem Fahrrad ohne Vorderreifen. Mein Fahrrad, er hat also nur mein Fahrrad geklaut. Dann hat die Nachbarn, ich wüsste aber bis heute nicht, wer ich so da, wem ich da danken muss, haben dann die Polizei gerufen. Und dann kam die Polizei, hat ihn festgenommen einfach. Und jetzt kommt es wahrscheinlich auch zu einem Gerichtstermin, wo ich hin muss. Und dann bin ich zur Polizei und habe mein Fahrrad abgeholt. Ja, mega gut. Ja, und jetzt habe ich es wieder. Aber jetzt führ ich es immer mit meiner Wohnung rein. Aber wie geil. Ja, aber perfekt. Ich dachte, es ist perfekt, weil jeder will ja mal, du willst, du willst ja mal zur Polizei müssen. Du willst dieses lange Mikrofon und dann so … Kein Kommentar. Erstmal, ich will gerne in den Gerichtsverhandlungen. Ich habe den noch nie gesehen. Aber kannst du in Tränen ausbrechen? Scheissegal, was ich … Ich dachte, mein Plan war, ganz in Schwarz zu kommen. Ganz in Schwarz, mit so einer grossen Sonnenbrille und so einem Schleier. Ja, auch. Und dann die ganze Zeit hinter der Zeitung. Ja, und so ein Übersetzer oder so einfach. Ach, viel zu... Ich will eine Riesenshow machen. Dafür, dass ich nur der Typ bin, dessen Fahrrad geklaut und gefunden wurde. Ja. Es ist komplett heile. Und du holst dir auch den besten Anwalt Deutschlands einfach, der dir einfach der Millionen Euro Schadensersatz raus holt. Weil ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, das ist das perfekte, du willst ja auch mal zur Polizei müssen, weil dir was geklaut wurde. Ja. Du willst ja auch eigentlich mal Anzeige erstatten. Ja. Das will man ja machen. Aber das ganze ohne den Struggle, dass dir wirklich was geklaut wurde. Ja. Ich habe auch das viel Geld fürs Fahrrad bezahlt, das wäre doof gewesen. Ich muss es nochmal zeigen. Das ist einfach süsses auch. Aber jetzt mit Blaulicht sogar. Jetzt mit Blau und Rotlicht. Moment, ich frage jetzt jemanden. Wenn das denn, der verunsiert sich wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber ich muss sagen, die Polizei Köln war da so toll, es fährt aber auch kein Deutsch schneller dafür, dass er Blaulicht anhat. Und da muss man auch mal sein. Ja, aber dann ein Schaudat an die Polizei Köln. Ja, vielen Dank, die haben ganz volle Arbeit geleistet und ich habe mein Fahrrad jetzt wieder und es ist komplett in Ordnung. Also ich habe mein Fahrrad, mein Fahrrad, mein Fahrradreifen wieder drangeschraubt und es ging wieder sofort. Perfekt. Ja, grossartig. Vielen Dank. Würde ich gut, aber auch tolle Nachbarn, die da auch mal ein Auge auf die Nachbarschaft haben. Das finde ich super. Nee, das ist auch wichtig. Da sind Busseboards. So. Oh, schau sie an. Ah, guck mal, da hat man den Controller. Ah, die haben ihr Smartphone in der Hand. Die kontrollieren das mit ihrem Smartphone. Nee, das sind einfach normalen Longboards. Ach, schade. Ich glaube, es geht ein bisschen bergab hier, kann das sein? Kann sein. Letztes Mal waren wir auf dem Dach, da haben wir euch auch viel zeigen können. Hier kann man das nicht so viel zeigen, auch weil wir ein bisschen an den Laptop gebunden sind. Da hinten ist ein berühmtes Geb Gebäude, keine Ahnung, wie das ist. Ja, dahinten wäre eigentlich die klassische Skyline, aber die kann man leider nicht sehen wegen den Bäumen. Fucking Bäume. Hier liegen auch ganz viele andere Menschen. Well. Nee, New York ist toll. Wir haben schon viel erlebt, wir haben noch viel vor in dieser Woche. Also heute Abend sehen wir das Aaron Sorkin-Stück, die Aaron Sorkin-Adaption von To Kill A Mockingbird mit Jeff Daniels wieder mal. Alter! Den haben wir schon mal vor ein paar Jahren hier gesehen in einem Play namens Blackbird, meine ich. Richtig, ja. Wo es um Kindesmissbrauch ging. Mit Michelle Williams. Mit Michelle Williams auch. Super gut. Kindesmissbrauch oder Michelle Williams? 70-30, würde ich sagen. Da freue ich mich sehr drauf heute Abend.
To Kill a Mockingbird ist ja ein Klassiker, den wir beide nicht kennen, weil wir keine Ahnung von gar nichts haben. Wir wissen nicht mehr, ob es ein Klassiker ist. Wir wissen auch nicht genau, was ein Mockingbird ist, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, aber das werden wir heute sehen, was es ist. Ich habe kurz mein Handy gesucht. Also ich glaube, Mockingbird ... Also meine Schätzung ist es, dass es so eine Art Vogel-Unlock-Köder ist, dass es so eine Art falscher Vogel ist. So Mock to Mock bedeutet ja auch so etwas Falsches, also ein Mockbird könnte ja auch so ein gefälschter Vogel sein, sowas in der Richtung. Das kann schon sein. Und Mocking könnte ja auch so Reizen heissen. Ich glaube, es ist ein Vogelköder. Also zum Fischen benutzt man ja zum Beispiel auch so einen Plastikfisch, wo dann der grosse Fisch reinbeiss, weil ich denke, das sieht so aus wie ich, das ist lecker, zack. Und ich glaube, sowas gibt es auch zum Vögel an Locken.
Kann schon sein. Das ist ja das Problem, die haben so ein grosses Problem mit ...
Die Canada-Goose ist ein grosses Problem in Amerika, weil es gibt viel zu viele Canada-Gees und die sind sehr aggressiv gegenüber Menschen, die beissen die Menschen und sowas.
Das Gegenteil von echten Kanadiern, unfreundliche Vögel. Genau, und Kanada beschwert sich auch sehr darüber, dass sie so genannt wurden und wollte, kann man die nicht Mexiko-Gees nennen oder sowas. Und früher waren die extrem gefährdet, weil die sehr dumm sind.
Und zwar, das ist auch ein bisschen fies, weil die Jäger haben dann eine von diesen Gänsen geklaut und haben denen dann, glaube ich, die Flügel abgeschnitten oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und dann hat die um Hilfe gerufen, die Gans, und dann sind ganz viele andere Gänse gekommen und die haben die alle abgeschossen. Und das ging super gut, weil die haben immer die gerufen und alle anderen Gänsen sind da hingekommen und dadurch hattest du halt eine so eine Ködergans. Menschen sind grauern. Und dann sind die gekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie die Flügel abgeschlossen haben. Ich habe nur gelesen, sie wurden flugunfähig gemacht oder fluchtunfähig, keine Ahnung, aber es war sehr grausam. Und weil es so grausam war, wurde das irgendwann verboten. Und dadurch, dass sie nicht mehr gejagt werden durften, gab es dann wahnsinnig viele. Und die leben überall in den Gärten und so und das ist ein Riesenproblem.
Ich habe aber noch keine gesehen, ich würde die gerne sehen, diese aggressiven Canada-Geese, die irgendwie dann auch die Menschen beißen und denen das Essen wegnehmen und so und richtig einfach nervig sind. Ich würde ja gerne einen Waschbär sehen. Oh ja, Raccoon! Die haben wir mal gesehen, die Raccoon, als wir in Harlem gewohnt haben, meine ich. Da haben wir nämlich mal einen Raccoon gesehen, einen Mülleimer. Aber hier in Williamsburg sowieso nicht, da sehen manche Menschen eher aus wie Waschbären, weil sie sich so Güter aufsetzen oder sowas. Eine illustre Gegend. Was ist denn sonst noch der Plan? Ansonsten sehen wir noch Hamilton natürlich, wir sehen noch ein Stück mit Adam Driver, dessen Namen ich vergessen habe. Genau, Burn This. Wir sind ja, sag ich mal, Promi sind ja Promijäger, dafür sind wir bekannt. Man weiss ja, viele dieser A-List-Hollywood-Stars sind ja auch am Broadway unterwegs und machen Theater. Zum Beispiel Michael Shannon ist jetzt auch bald in einem Stück und so was. Jake Gyllenhaal. Jake Gyllenhaal ist auch gerade aktiv, haben aber leider keine Karte mehr bekommen, ist schon ausverkauft. Ich glaube, es fängt auch erst an Ende Juli, habe ich mal nicht gelesen. Aber naja. Und auf jeden Fall gehen wir bald zu einem Stück mit Adam Driver. Cool. Nur zwei Personen Stück, Adam Driver und die Torspielerin kenne ich nicht. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, weil wir sind ja beide grosse Adam Driver Fans, Patterson, Kylo Ren. Jetzt der neue Film, The Dead Don't Die, Jim Jarmusch, kann ich eh gross ans Herz legen. Sehr abgefahren. Schaut euch den absurdesten Film, den ich in den letzten Jahren im Kino gesehen habe, an, Jim Jarmusch, The Dead Don't Die. Also ich war aber auch der einzige im Kino, der gelacht hat die ganze Zeit. Alle anderen waren einfach nur... Kein gutes Zeichen. Alle anderen wollten einfach einen Horrorfilm sehen, glaube ich, und wurden einfach komplett enttäuscht, natürlich. War fantastisch. Hast du Under the Silver Lake, glaube ich, hast du ja gesehen? Nee. Mit Andrew Garfield, derfield, der soll auch ziemlich abgefahren sein. Der war irgendwie, viele haben sich auf den Film gefreut, aber dann hat er gar keinen Release weitläufig bekommen. Aber muss ich auch noch angucken. Okay. Ich muss auch mehr Filme schauen, ich schaue kaum noch Filme. Ich schaue keine Serie mehr, weil ich keine Lust habe. Du bist in Tschernobyl drin gerade. Ja, genau, habe ich jetzt angefangen, bin aber auch schon fast durch, weil jetzt hat der Film vorher gewusst, was ich gar nicht wusste, das war acht, aber ja, ich bin schon fast durch. Fantastische Serie, eine ganz toll recherchierte Serie, wo man auch merkt, da hat sich jemand so sehr eingelesen wahrscheinlich, dass er da dachte, okay, da sind so viele Anekdoten drin und es geht in dieser Serie ja auch kaum um Figuren. Ich finde es sehr, sehr auf das Ereignis geschrieben. Aber die Serie fängt an mit der Hauptfigur, die sich umbringt. Damit geht's los, das ist die erste Szene. Ja, aber... Und dann ist die Frage, ja, aber natürlich ist es schwer zu trennen, ob die Serie cool ist oder das Ereignis einfach sehr interessant, aber ich finde die Figuren schon wichtig. Es ist schon eine sehr ereignis-driven Serie, klar. Ich finde die auch super gemacht, ich finde auch die Figuren, die sie erzählen, spannend. Aber so richtig um die geht es nicht und die hätte sie auch mit anderen erzählen können. Aber es ist einfach ganz toll, finde ich dann immer, wenn man merkt, da hat sich jemand einfach so sehr mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt, dass man so viel darüber lernt auch. Und da schwingen ja auch so viele andere Diskussionen mit, wie viel Verantwortung hat man eigentlich als Mensch, mit Wissen umzugehen.
Und man merkt ja auch, wie dumm damals die Bevölkerung war, dass die gar keine Ahnung hatten. Wir hatten ja gestern auch kurz drüber gesprochen, da sind die einfach nachts, als es in Luft geflogen sind, auf so eine Brücke geladen. Die sind ja hingegangen, um sich anzugucken, wie so ein Reaktorbrennen, wo wir heute das anpassen. Ich spiele das. Genau, einfach weil die so und da denkt man ja, okay, nebenan waren Leute in der Lage, Atomkraft zumindest kurz so zu kontrollieren, dass es eine Stadt mit Strom versorgen kann. Auf der anderen Seite hat man die andere Bevölkerung aber noch nicht mehr in Kenntnis gesetzt, was das überhaupt passiert. Die haben gar keine Ahnung gehabt. Die haben sich über die Gefahren gar nicht bewusst. Also ganz fantastisch und vor allem eine grosse Empfehlung von mir, sich parallel auch den Podcast anzuhören. Es gibt nämlich zu jeder einzelnen Serienfolge noch einen einstündigen Podcast mit Craig Mason, der Creator und Drehbuchautor, der immer interviewt wird. Und es ist ein super toller Podcast, wo der noch mal ein bisschen ins Detail geht und auch so ein bisschen Hintergründe aufrollt. Ganz toll, ich bin ja ohnehin großer Craig-Mason-Fan, weil ich schon lange den Script-Notes-Podcast lese, äh, höre. Ja. Der ist ja da dabei und deswegen habe ich auch schon, vor vier Jahren meinte der auch schon, ja, ich pitche jetzt hier so eine Serie und so und der hat dann immer wieder erzählt, wie das dann weitergeht und deswegen war es so cool, endlich die Serie rauszukommen. Aber tatsächlich, ich weiss nicht, wie Craig Mason aussieht und ich will jetzt auch nicht wissen, wie der aussieht. Und deswegen, ich habe jetzt mir auch auf iTunes die ganze Serie nochmal geholt und da gibt es viel Bonusmaterial und das konnte ich mir nicht anschauen, weil irgendwie habe ich so dieses Ding, ich will nicht wissen, wie der aussieht, weil ich habe ein ganz klares Bild von dem, weil ich schon seit fünf Jahren den Podcast höre. Aber ist der mit ihm immer? Ja, ja, doch, der ist immer, ja, genau. Das ist John August und Craig Mason, es sind immer Script Notes Podcast. Das sind immer die beiden. Ich habe mir die Namen nie gemerkt, ich bin auch nicht so regelmäßig wie du wahrscheinlich, aber... Ja, aber ganz fantastisch. Und auch ein sehr, sehr geiler Podcast, weil die natürlich auch über Drehbuchautoren gehen und auch wirklich so Sachen, die wirklich auch nur Drehbuchautoren interessiert. Also wirklich genau wie die Industrie angeht und wie man die so Verträge schreibt und wer wie viel Geld bekommt und so. Und es ist super interessant, aber auch natürlich Handwerk, wie man dann tatsächlich schreibt. Also ganz fantastisch und deswegen sehr, sehr cool.
Und ja, grosse Empfehlung. Große Empfehlung auf jeden Fall, Tschernobyl schauen, ja. Auf HBO kann man auf Sky anschauen, was ärgerlich ist, weil Sky der schlechteste Player der Welt ist, aber da muss man durch. Da muss man durch. Ich würde auch wahnsinnig gern den Namen der Rose-Serie sehen, auch weil ein Schauspieler von unserer Serie da mitspielt. Und ich habe mich da auch schon darauf gefreut. Der Damian spielt mit den Azo. Ah, der Dan, oder was? Dan spielt da mit, Azo von Melk heisst die Figur, glaube ich. Das ist die Christian-Slater-Figur aus dem damaligen Film. Was sehr cool ist und ich würde das einfach wahnsinnig gerne sehen, aber es ist fucking Sky Ticket. Und Sky Ticket ist die schlecht programmierteste App. Also Sky ist wirklich unglaublich miserabel, hundmiserabel. Ich weiss auch nicht, was da los ist. Warum? Weil man denkt ja immer so, die Konkurrenz belebt das Geschäft. Und irgendwie, wenn Netflix was vormacht, dann ziehen alle nach. Es gibt keine Android-TV-App, alleine schon nicht. Für Apple-TV geht es aber auch nicht, wenn du im englischen US-Store bist. Und wenn du es dann mal hinkriegst, dann ist oft Verbindungsprobleme und auch nicht HD. Das ist wirklich alles falsch gelaufen. Und ich ärgere mich jedes Mal, wenn Sky eine gute Serie herausbringt. Jedes Mal. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es auch natürlich ein guter Qualitäts-Threshold, weil wenn man sich mal eine Serie auf Sky anschaut, dann ist sie richtig gut. Und wenn wir eine Sky-Serie empfehlen, dann ist sie richtig gut. Ja, dann ist sie wirklich besser, als wenn wir sie auf Netflix empfehlen würden. Succession ist auch gut auf Sky. Kann ich auch anschauen. Aber gibt es nicht mehr, stimmt. Die haben dann oft auch so Sachen, dass sie die nur einen Monat haben oder so die Serien. Und dann habe ich die ersten vier Folgen geschaut, dann gab es die Serie nicht mehr und dann denkst du dir, soll ich jetzt auf iTunes nochmal alle kaufen? Es ist super bescheuert. Es ist bescheuert, man weiss es nicht genau. Glaubst du, dieses ganze Serien-Plattform-Ding wird besser in der Zukunft oder immer noch schlechter? Ich glaube, wir sind gerade in dieser Phase, wo sich alles aufsplittet. Natürlich kommen noch andere Sachen dazu, es kommen noch Big Player wie Apple hinzu und Telekom macht jetzt auch immer mehr. Disney macht jetzt auch den eigenen. Join hat jetzt auch noch grösser, das war damals MacStone, Disney kommt jetzt mit dem Disney Plus um die Ecke. Es fächert sich gerade so nervig auf, glaube ich. Aber so eine es sich irgendwann wieder zusammen, wo du da wirklich nur noch eine Plattform hast? Ich glaube schon. Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, dann werden hier und da welche übernommen und so, dann kommt da wieder Größeres zusammen. Diese Auffächerung ist, glaube ich, erst mal nervig, weil jeder seine eigene App programmieren muss und so. Aber irgendwann lebt diese Konkurrenz halt auch so, dass das Geschäft, glaube ich, dass dann die Apps wieder ganz cool sein müssen, zwangs glaube ich, weil man sich für die coolere benutzerfreundliche Oberfläche entscheidet, wahrscheinlich, zwangs glaube ich, weiß ich nicht genau. Oh, ist hier viel los, ey. Überall hast du Helikopter am Start, New York ist so geschäftlich. Ey, ich habe auch jedes Mal, wenn ich ein Flugzeug hier drüber fliegen sehe, denke ich mir, fuck, es geht wieder los. Jedes Mal ist es einfach noch drin, aber die fliegen hier teilweise auch echt tief, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Oh, da muss ich auch noch hin, hat mir ein Hörer empfohlen, 9-11 Memorial Museum. Übrigens noch mal ganz kurz, stellvertretend vielen Dank an alle, die uns Tipps gegeben haben für New York. Viele gute Sachen dabei, schaue ich einiges an. Und unter anderem das Memorial Museum. Ihr wart ja, Tarkan und du wart ja vor zwei Jahren bei dem Memorial. Auch da. Du meintest, Tarkan war sehr betroffen. Tarkan war sehr betroffen, hat ein paar Tränen verdrückt. Wir standen dann da rum. Tarkan wollte prima, dass ich Instagram-Fotos von ihm mache, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht mehr. Eins von beiden war der Fall. Jedenfalls kamen da ein paar Flugzeuge vorbei. Man sah nicht mehr in den Gebäuden. Es ist wirklich gruselig in New York. Ja, weil die Wolken hat so, und du siehst ja perspektivisch, siehst du nicht genau, wie weit die entfernt sind. Ich verstehe aber auch diese Videos nicht von Leuten. Die Leute ja dann schon das erste Flugzeug auch teilweise gefilmt. Ja, das ist merkwürdig. Weil es so tief kam. Aber eigentlich ist das hier, jedes Flugzeug sieht so aus, als ob es gleich irgendein Gebäude reinfliegt. Aber wenn du hier wohnst, hast du vielleicht schon im Gefühl, okay, das ist jetzt wirklich aktiv. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, hier zu wohnen, niemals. Es ist so intensiv. New York ist einfach, also die Amerikaner habe ich generell, das ist ja wahnsinnig pauschal und so, aber muss man auch erstmal einfach durch, Hamsraus' Work-Life-Balance hinzubekommen. Einfach Work-Hard, Play-Hard, das hat sich hier auf die Fahne geschrieben, alle arbeiten wahnsinnig viel, müssen sich hier auch, sonst kann man sich kein Leben hier leisten. Aber New York hat es einfach verstanden, mit den vielen kleinen Parks oder diesem grossen Central Park den Ausgleich zu schaffen.
Und du hast hier an jeder Ecke so kleine Spas oder so kleine Oasen in diesem Dschungel. Tatsächlich auch Meditationsstudios. In diesem Grossartdschungel hast du so viele Orte, die dir helfen, damit klarzukommen. Das ist schon ganz interessant. Ich glaube, hier hältst du es einfach nicht aus. Und ich finde, wir als Leute, die dann einfach uns einfach eine Woche lang auch diesem Tubel aussetzen, reicht dann nach einer Woche oder zwei auch diese Stadt total. Es ist so ein bisschen wie ein Vergnügungspark. Du gehst gerne hin, du schlägst dir deinen Bauch voll, aber du willst nicht in einem Vergnügungspark leben. Also so sehe ich zum... Naja, okay, jetzt... Ich weiss nicht, ich habe gerade einen Zaubertrick gekauft, ich bin erstmal für alles zu haben. Ich habe gerade für 80 Jahre einen fucking Zauber, was ist denn jetzt hier los? Ich glaube, unser Akku geht auch langsam leer. Wo sind wir denn? Bei 24 Prozent. Ich sehe es gar nicht. Echt gut. Es geht, es geht besser als ich dachte eigentlich. Wir müssen ja noch speichern und das veröffentlichen. Das heisst, wir sehen uns eigentlich gleich wieder auf unserem Dach. Wenn es weitergeht mit Teil zwei von dieser fantastischen Ausgabe des YouTube-Ufos live aus New York 2019. Es ist ja wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht, hier schon im Central Park. Wir sagen tschau tschau. Und wir sehen uns gleich wieder auf dem Dach. Und da sind wir auch schon. Oh ne, herzlich willkommen zurück. Im YouTube-Ufo, Teil Nummer drei. Wir sind immer noch in New York, wir sind mittlerweile auf unserem Dach. Ich glaube, man kann uns nicht sehen. Es sind ein paar Stunden später sind wir jetzt. Ich habe den Trick schon ein paar Mal aufgeführt, den ich gerade heute Mittag gekauft habe. Und ihr seht die New Yorker Skyline im Hintergrund, uns dafür gar nicht im Vordergrund. Das ist auch nicht so wichtig. Aber es fällt auch gut, die Skyline ist ja auch das Wichtigste heute hier. Das ist ja auch ein Podcast. Von den 80 Euro, die Stefan ausgegeben hat, hat er schon vier Euro wieder reingeholt. Weil Leute den Trick wissen wollten. Richtig, ja. Wir waren gerade im Theater. Wir haben gerade gesehen To Kill a Mockingbird und Spoiler Alert, Mockingbird ist Nachtigall. Nachtigall. Beziehungsweise sogar eine Drossel, eine Art Drossel, die es im Deutschen nicht gibt. So eine meckernde Drossel. Es hat sich herausgestellt, es hat sich sehr schnell ergeben, als man das Theaterstück gesehen hat, ja es geht hier um Nachtigalle. Und hier hinten kann man die Skyline sehen, wir sind wieder in Brooklyn, ähnlich wie wir auch letztes Jahr waren um uns herum. Wir sind so ein bisschen im ruhigen Teil, waren gerade aber auch in in Manhattan. Und es ist ja auch unglaublich, weil wir heute hatten es schon von Gerüchen, aber ich finde, worüber man auch reden muss bei New York, ist die Temperatur, weil ich glaube, es gibt nirgendwo so massive Temperaturschwankungen.
Also hier ist gerade unglaublich warm, also man muss sagen, hier ist gerade um die 35 Grad, das sind 1000 Grad Fahrenheit, glaube ich, umgerechnet, also zu heiß. Ich schwitze als Einziger, aber habe ich immer das Gefühl, da ist mein T-Shirt immer komplett voll geschwitzt, weil entweder sind die alle zum Klima, haben sich angeglichen und angepasst und sind das gewohnt, oder ich schwitze einfach viel, weiß ich nicht, ist mir sonst noch nicht aufgefallen. Und dann gibt es aber das Problem, dass man immer falsch angezogen ist, weil alle Gebäude sind halt auf, weiß nicht, zwölf Grad runtergekühlt. Aber brutal klimatisiert. Aber das ist mir schon häufiger aufgefallen. Gestern hat auch jemand zu mir gesagt, da habe ich ein T-Shirt gekauft in so einem Laden in Brooklyn. Und der hat auch gesagt, du kommst aus Deutschland, ja wow, da ist es wahrscheinlich genauso heiß wie hier, aber ihr habt auch keine Klimaanlagen. Und dann habe ich auch gesagt, ja, das stimmt schon auch. Deutschland ist nicht dafür gemacht, zu klimatisieren. Deutschland war immer ein Land, was man nicht klimatisieren musste, weil die Temperatur gut war. Ich weiss auch nicht, dass mit diesem harten Klimatisieren so eine gute Idee ist, weil du stehst in der Metro am Bahnsteig, super schwül, super heiß und dann machst du einen Schritt in die U-Bahn und dir ist kalt. Es wird wirklich einfach runtergekühlt, von 40 Grad auf 18 Grad einfach in einer Sekunde runtergeballert. Wie gesagt, es ist 35 Grad, ich bin mit einem T-Shirt in das Theater gegangen und ich habe gefroren, ich habe gezittert, wirklich. Ich habe auch wegen Aaron Sorkin teilweise Gänsehaut bekommen oder vielleicht aber auch einfach, weil es sehr kalt war. Aber man muss tatsächlich sagen, so die letzte halbe Stunde des Stücks, der Raum hat sich immer mehr zu einem Lazarett entwickelt. Das Publikum hat nicht gut reagiert auf die Kälte. Überhaupt nicht. Am Anfang so respektvolle Stille und gegen Ende wirklich konstantes Röcheln. Und Niesen auch. Also ich glaube, du hattest so eine RPM von 100, so Röchel pro Minute. Es war eigentlich konstantes Röcheln. Ich glaube, es sind 1500 Leute oder so. Da reicht es ja schon, wenn alle paar Sekunden mal, wenn jeder pro Minute einmal hustet, dass du schon eine ordentliche Frequenz im Raum hast. Das ist wie so ein Untergrundrauschen, Hintergrundrauschen. Das wäre interessant, ich habe mir die ganze Zeit vorgestellt, dass das Publikum wie bei Tekken so eine Lebensanzeige hat, die am Ende rot geblinkt hat, weil das Publikum nicht mehr gut drauf war. Eine Frau hat kontinuierlich geniesst, die ganze Zeit ... Es wurde immer schlimmer. Irgendwann waren Leute so sauer und haben sich so umgeregt gemacht. Ich glaube, die Klimaanlage war einfach ein paar Grad zu krass eingestellt. Ich habe auch nur darauf gewartet, dass irgendwie Sanitäter reinkommen und so anfangen, die ersten Leute rauszunehmen. So ganz leise und respektvoll, so pssst, während das Stück läuft. Es war echt hart. Aber es ist auch tatsächlich krass, wenn du so durch die Strassen läufst und du läufst an so Häusern vorbei. Bei jedem Fenster ist einfach so ein vibrierender Kasten, der einfach die Klimaanlage ist. Und das ist schon echt hart. Also wo man sagt, okay, wenn du das gewohnt bist, dass Geschäfte so hart klimatisiert sind und alles, dann hast du es auch zu Hause. Aber ich bin fast ein bisschen froh, dass es in Deutschland nicht so ist, dass du da so ein bisschen,
du schwitzt halt, aber dann bist du halt nach einer Stunde, hast dich daran gewöhnt und dann passt schon. Aber hier hast du keine Chance,
dein Körper ist konstant im Ausnahmezustand, weil er entweder hoch regulieren muss, wenn es zu kalt ist oder runter regulieren muss, aber er ist ständig so.
Normalerweise, klar, du gehst raus und schwitzt eine Stunde, aber es passt. Aber hier, also bist du dir ständig bewusst, dass die Temperatur gerade extrem ist, entweder niedrig oder hoch?
Hier muss man wirklich umge... Also ich müsste mir jetzt einen Pulli mitnehmen, falls ich irgendwo rein will. Das ist das Interessante daran. Draußen ist es unglaublich schwül und warm.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen, morgen abends eine Jacke mitzunehmen fürs Theater innen drin. Oder wenn man abends noch irgendwo reingeht oder sowas, da brauche ich dann eine Jacke, weil da ist zu kalt. Wenn du reingehst, musst du die Jacke anziehen. Es gibt auch so einen Kleiderständer am Eingang, nur wenn du reinkommst, ziehst du die Jacke an. Es wäre eigentlich gut, wenn man für draußen, draußen müsste so ein Kleiderhaken stehen. Man kommt draußen und hängt die Jacke auf. Das müsste es eigentlich geben. Es ist einfach alles ein bisschen umgedreht hier.
Es ist echt total absurd. Und wenn wir hier auf dem Dach sind, dann erinnern wir uns natürlich mit wohliger Erinnerung noch an vor zwei Jahren, als wir auf einem solchen Dach Fourth of July gefeiert haben. Zusammen mit Hazel Brugger, interessanterweise, waren wir auf einem New Yorker Dach, wir haben sie zufällig getroffen. und wir sind dieses Jahr, glaube ich, völlig unabsichtlich, wieder während des Fourth of July.
Ja, völlig unabsichtlich.
Und eine weitere Chance, diesen Feiertag nicht zu verstehen.
Ich habe vor ein paar Wochen, als ich unserem Airbnb-Host, nee, das war jetzt kurz vor der Reise, habe ich kurz in meinem Kopf gehabt, weil es klingt so ähnlich, First of July.
Ich dachte kurz, First of July wäre der, habe ich dann kurz gesagt, dann kommen wir dann abends da hin und dann ist es, kommen wir da abends an mit dem Flugzeug und dann ist es direkt so eine Partystimmung, vielleicht ganz gut, um einen Jetlag zu überleben. In meinem Kopf war ich mir sicher, es ist der First of July und ich war wirklich Sekunden davor, jetzt schon geschrieben, unserem Airbnb-Host einen Happy First of July zu wünschen. Was hätte ich gedacht haben müssen, wenn ich das abgeschickt hätte. Ja, danke. Was hat er gedacht? Also ich glaube, es ist der Unabhängigkeitstag. Ich glaube, die Unabhängigkeitserklärung unterzeichnet. Genau. Aber man sagt auch Happy Fourth. Also habe ich das auch schon ein paar Mal gehört, weil jetzt machen ja viele so die letzten Einkäufe und so. Glaube ich, ich meine, oder ist morgen, oder ich weiß es nicht ganz genau. Morgen ist der vierte, ja. Aber ist denn morgen auch Geschäfte zu und alles so? Das weiss ich gar nicht, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, dass die Geschäfte zu ist eh nicht so. Aber es ist total merkwürdig, weil so die eigenen Feiertage kennt man ja total gut und jeder hat so seinen eigenen Charakter. Ostern hat einen ganz eigenen Charakter, ganz anders als Weihnachten, wohingegen das für den Ausländer schwierig nachzuvollziehen ist. Wahrscheinlich nicht so ersichtlich ist, weil einer hat Weihnachtsleute, dann hast du so Hasenleute und das ist erstmal so beides weird. Und genauso schwer ist es für uns oder für mich zumindest, den Fourth of July, also den Charakter zu verstehen. Der Charakter ist Silvester, finde ich. Man trifft sich, also man hat tagsüber einen normalen Tag. Es ist wie Silvester im Jahr, im Sommer. Und alle besorgen sich was, abends wird gerackletet oder gegrillt, weil es halt warm ist.
Aber was ist das klassische Fourth of July-Essen? Ich glaube Barbecue auf dem Dach, was wir hier in New York, in Williamsburg zumindest.
Das ist der klassische Abend, man geht tagsüber gut einkaufen.
Wir sitzen ja gerade an einem Tisch, der von unseren Nachbarn schon hergerichtet wurde morgen für die Party, die offensichtlich auch hier feiern. Also ich glaube, das ist eine klassische, man wird irgendwo eingeladen, bringt ein bisschen was zu essen mit und dann wird da entspannt gegrillt, getrunken und abends das Feuerwerk geguckt, glaube ich. Aber es ist jetzt kein Feiertag, der irgendwie so ein Maskottchen hat oder so ein Lied oder so, wo man sagt, das hat ah, okay, Charakter irgendwie, verstehe ich. Thanksgiving verstehe ich tatsächlich viel besser, weil da hast du so dieses klar, du hast dann, also ich kenne es eigentlich nur das Adams Family, dass du halt dann so diese Pocahontas Theaterstück führst du vor und dann ah, die Urinwohner und wir, wie nett waren wir doch zu denen und so, man denkt sich, war das wirklich so und dann gibt es einen gross Troutan und dann ist alles in Ordnung und man muss sich mit den doofen Schwiegereltern abfinden. Wir werden in Indiana verprügelt und so. Check ich. Man kennt das, ja. Aber Fourth of July verstehe ich nicht wirklich. Ich glaube, also Fourth of July hat mich vor allem nachhaltig beeindruckt, weil es das längste Feuerwerk hatte, was ich jemals gesehen hatte. Ja, zu lang, muss man auch sagen. Das war, es war, vor allem, als Deutscher kennt man, man freut sich noch auf Feuerwerkwerks. Man hat den nicht so häufig. Und man denkt immer, als Kind dachte ich auch immer, wenn man so ein städtisches Feuerwerk hatte, was so automatisiert ist, am Ende von der Kirmes zum Beispiel gab es das bei uns immer. Da dachte ich immer, oh, jetzt muss es noch länger gehen, oh, jetzt kann doch nicht jetzt schon vorbei sein, oh, wo ist denn der grosse Knall? Wo sind die grossen Dinger? Und hier beim Fourth of July war das extrem, weil ab Minute zwei fing das an, wir sind ja hier sehr weit weg vom Hudson River, aber da ist das Feuerwerk. Und es hat selbst hier in Williamsburg noch den ganzen Himmel erleuchtet. Und das ging dann bis, sagen wir mal, zwei Stunden. Und irgendwann ist die Stimmung auch gekippt. Irgendwann haben sich die Leute auch dann weggedreht vom Feuerwerk und wollten reden, aber da war es dann zu laut.
Bei mir ist es tatsächlich genau das Gegenteil. Bei mir ist jedes Feuerwerk zu lang.
Jedes Feuerwerk, das länger als zwei Minuten ist, würde ich sagen, ist bei mir zu lang.
Ich will einfach bam, bam, bam, bam, bam und dann ist auch gut.
So und dann hat es sich erledigt, weil ein Feuerwerk hat keine vernünftige Dramaturgie irgendwie.
Du kannst nicht so, ja klar, natürlich erzählst du mir die Feinheiten von wegen, erst die gelben, dann die grünen, dann die blauen und da so von mir aus. Erst die Zissler, dann die grossen Bomben. Ich nehme das nicht an. Der Goldregen, auch guter Erfekt. Ich nehme das nicht an. Für mich macht ein Feuerwerk primär Spaß, wenn ich selber einen Böller in der Hand habe und wenn ich selber irgendwie als Kind irgendwie so eine kleine Jägermeisterflasche kaputt mache mit einem Böller. Das macht Spaß.. Feuerwerk anschauen interessiert mich nicht, deswegen bin ich auch gespannt. Vielleicht werde ich mich einfach reinsetzen und ein bisschen lesen über die Geschichte der Unabhängigkeitserklärung. Das können wir gerne machen. Finde ich ganz gut, morgen mal so ein bisschen sich in die Bibliothek zu setzen, vielleicht ein bisschen was zu erfahren. Morgen für mich grosser Museumstag, weiß ich noch nicht. Wo gehst du rein? Ich würde gerne in die neue Galerie gehen. Die neue Galerie ist ein Museum für ... Du bist acht Stunden lang über den Atlantik geflogen, um dir dann deutsche Kunst anzuschauen. Die es ja nur hier gibt. Auch wahrscheinlich aus einem guten Grund, weil die wahrscheinlich weggeklaut wurde damals, als die Amerikaner Deutschland besetzt haben. Ja stimmt, dieses Monuments Man Film, ne? Haben die die Bilder zurückgegeben schon, ne? Ne, die sind jetzt an der neuen Galerie hier in New York. Da würde ich gerne hin. Ich würde gerne ins MoMA gehen, ich würde noch mal gerne ins Metz gehen, ins Naturhistorische Museum, weiss ich noch nicht genau, was man da morgen alles macht. Tatsächlich, vor kurzer Zeit war ja so diese Met Gala, diese Metropolitan Gala, wo dann alle so ganz exquisite Kleider hatten, irgendwie Lady Gaga mit sechs verschiedenen Outfits und so und super krass. Und das hat dann auch so Bilder ein bisschen rumgemacht. Und ich war so maximal verwirrt, weil ich kenne das Metropolitan Museum. Und es ist halt so ein Museum, wo halt so Römerhelme und Ritterrüstungen ausgestellt sind. Und ich habe das im Kopf überhaupt gar nicht zusammengebracht mit dieser high-crass-fashion-Celebrity-Welt. Aber dann gibt es auch die Metropolitan Opera. Und ich darf es gar nicht. Was genau ist Metro-Metro-Met? Was ist das, Met? Ich verstehe es überhaupt nicht. Wir finden es ja aus, dass Metropolitan... Ich habe es nicht hundertprozentig verstanden. Oh, guck mal, jetzt sieht man es auch sogar ein bisschen. Hallo. Es wird immer mehr wie Blair Witch. Es hat heute Morgen schon angefangen. Es ist wirklich Blair Witch. Es ist die Dramaturgie auch von Blair Witch. Es ist Blair Witch mit mehr Pro-Replacement von Snapple, das muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Das ist das Einzige, was den Film ein bisschen weniger gruselig gemacht hat. Du hast geändert. Das funktioniert nicht.
Wir müssen auch mal wieder zurück zur Fantasie gehen. Wir müssen Fragen auch einfach offen lassen, Stefan. Ja, na ja. Wir können nicht einfach alles googeln immer. Das ist doch langweilig. Aber da ist auch ein bisschen die Community daran schuld, die uns austreibt zu fantasieren und uns einfleucht, doch bitte die Wahrheit zu sagen. Ja, das stimmt. Die dann immer alles korrigiert. Die Korrektur wahren. Ja, das ist richtig. Ist ja auch irgendwo richtig. Naja. Ich war heute noch ein bisschen im Central Park und durch die Gegend gelaufen und habe mir dann, ich habe versucht, die Frage zu beantworten, mir selbst, was zuerst da war, New York oder der Central Park. Und da gibt es ja auch so grosse Felsen und Felsformationen und so. Und da dachte ich mir schon so, die kann man schlecht hierher verfrachten. Nee, da kamen grosse Helikopter an, diese Doppelten, weisst du, mit Doppelmotoren,
und die teilweise auch, dann kamen welche teilweise mit vier Motoren und so und haben
die grosse Steine hierher gepflanzt. Aber das waren riesige Felsen und die waren überwachsen und da muss man ja in den grossen, nee, nee, ich glaube Central Park war zuerst da und New York außenrum. Ich glaube, das Empire State Building war zuerst da, dann hat man gesagt, wir bauen darum die Stadt mit hohen Häusern und in der Mitte hat man dann immer gesagt, wir brauchen aber irgendwo, Leute, wir brauchen ein paar Parks. Ja, komm, wir haben den Central Park. Dann haben die ganzen Häuser wieder abgerissen und dann hat die diesen vierjährigen Park hingesetzt. Ja, es kann sein, aber hat Spaß gemacht. Wir haben ein bisschen rumgelaufen, schön eingecremt, Sonnencreme, bisschen Link gelaufenaufen. Ich bin auf der Suche nach New Yorks Besten. Ich würde gerne so eine Zitlos-Show mit New Yorks Besten, die 25 besten New Yorker Dinge machen. Ich war schon im besten New Yorker Pizzaladen, da waren wir bei Joe's Pizza hier, dann waren wir im besten New Yorker Sandwich, habe ich heute Morgen von erzählt, bei Faikos. Und heute war ich dann noch beim besten New Yorker Donutladen, Dough, D-U-O-U-G-H, wie der Teig. Und den gab es in so einem ganz weirden, in so einem Food District, wie eine Markthalle am Grand Central, an der Grand Central Station, dem grossen Bahnhof hier in New York. Und da gab es eine Filiale von Doe. Oh, jetzt geht das Feuerwerk los! Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das war eine Rakete. Eine Rakete, weil jeder kann ja auch hier, es wird ja auch geböllert. Der New Yorker böllert ja auch. Ach, man darf privat böllert. Der New Yorker böllert? Der New Yorker böllert hier. Ah, okay. Und deswegen sind hier so ein paar Leute, habe ich auch gerade schon gehört, die sind schon am Böllern. Deswegen ist es ja wie Silvester, es ist wie die Vortage von Silvester, wo dann auch schon mal so eine Akkette losgeht. Aber es gibt ja auch Silvester hier, ne? Also das ist ja dann… Die haben doppelt Geböller. Doppelt. Ja. Aber es ist ja gut verteilt über das Jahr. Ja, aber trotzdem so alle halbe Jahr, ich glaube, wenn du jetzt sagen würdest, wir machen jetzt Weihnachten alle halbes Jahr, würde man auch irgendwann sagen, jetzt hör mir auf mit den Girlanden. Aber ich denke mir hier, als Deutscher könntest du eigentlich, du müsstest so Polenböller mitbringen. Und so, ich glaube, das Feuerwerk in Deutschland ist krasser als hier. Hier kriegst du halt ein paar Raketchen, so, aber wenn du diese lauten Polenböller, die es in Deutschland sehr einfach zu kaufen gibt, aufgrund der Nähe zu Polen. Ich glaube, da kannst du dir richtig Feinde machen. Ich glaube, du kannst dir richtig auftrumpfen am 4th of July. Boom! Die Deutschen sind wieder da. Die Deutschen sind wieder da und alle schrecken zusammen. Da haben alle hier so 9-11-Flashbacks und wir sind dann schuld. Polen. Du hast Donuts geholt und du warst, ich weiss nicht, hab dir auch schon erzählt, du warst bei dem Laden von Chef's Table. Ich war, genau, und zwar gibt es ja Christina Tosi, von der ich ein grosser Fan bin, ist ein Pastry-Chef, also so ein Nachspeisen-Köchin. Zuckerbäckerin. Zuckerbäckerin, Süsswarenbäckerin und die hat hier verschiedene Läden, die heissen Milk Bar und die sind ganz ulkig, aber auch ehrlich gesagt, da war ich ein bisschen enttäuscht von, weil ich glaube nämlich die grossen Läden, wo sie dann auch ist, wo eine grosse Bäckerei auch im Hintergrund ist, wo man auch noch schön essen kann, die sind glaube ich eher in L.A. und hier sind eher so kleine Läden, da kann man reingehen und sich dann bereits gemachte Dinge kaufen. Ich habe ja mal gesagt, er setzt Wasser immer durch Milch. Ja, und sie hat es auf die Spitze getrieben. Wenn du zum Beispiel eine Suppe machst oder so, Tomatensuppe und dann denkt man, okay, Wasser plus Tomaten, stopp. Milch plus Tomaten, weil Milch ist immer besser als Wasser, weil Milch hat Fett und Fett ist Schmacksträger und Fettträger. Und deswegen gut. Aber sie ist mir noch mal einen Schritt voraus. Was ist ihre Idee? Sie hat nämlich gesagt, was ist das Beste, wenn man ein Müsli isst? Die Milch, die den Geschmack des Müsli angenommen hat. Und jetzt ist Milch ja nicht nur... Was kann man dann damit machen? Weil Milch ist ja auch ein Mittel zur Weiterverarbeitung für, sagen wir, Soft-Eis, Shakes, für Shakes, für alles. Im Tee, im Kaffee. Genau. Und dann deswegen hat sie… Milcheis. Ja, ja, alles gut. Und deswegen hat sie sich überlegt, Cereal-Milk rauszubringen. Und ich hätte ein fantastisches Cereal-Milk-Eis. Es ist wirklich mega. Also es ist genial, weil du kannst ja dann eigentlich auch… Kann man Cereal-Milk so kaufen? Kann man auch so kaufen, ja. Dann kannst du ja Cereal machen mit Cereal-Milk. Es ist eigentlich aber ein bisschen blöd. Also sie macht es sehr aufwendig, sie filtert quasi, sie hat grosse Behälter, wo sie dann Cornflakes drin hat und dann filtert sie die Milch und unten kommt das raus. Aber was macht sie mit den Cornflakes? Das weiß ich nicht genau, die werden dann an Obdachlose verschenkt vielleicht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich glaube, es ist aber viel einfacher, weil du musst ja einfach, was da drin bleibt, ist ja der Zucker in der Milch. Der bleibt Zucker und hat ein paar Geschmacksdinger drin. Ich glaube, man kann das einfach selber herstellen, man macht sich das mittlerweile anders. Ich fand das jedenfalls sehr lecker. Ich habe dann so ein Soft-Eis bekommen, und außen waren dann so Cereal-Streusel drum, aber das Soft-Eis hat auch nach Cereal geschmeckt. Das war wirklich fantastisch lecker. Da habe ich mir auch noch so einen Cookie bestellt, den ich auch schon mal nachgebacken habe. Ich wollte eigentlich einen Crack Pie, das ist ja ein berühmter Kuchen, der hat sich Crack Pie genannt, weil der so abhängig macht, den ich schon ein paar Mal nachgebacken habe, auch oft für Kollegen. Den wollte ich eigentlich mal probieren, wie der im Original schmeckt, weil ich ihn nur halt von mir kenne und den schon immer ganz cool finde, aber ich hätte ihn gerne mal hier probiert. Gab es leider nicht. Mega gut. Aber ich bin gerade glücklich geworden, weil mir gerade eingefallen hat, dass ich im Kühlschrank noch Sachen von ihr habe, weil ich habe nämlich das grosse Best-of von ihr gekauft. Schau dich unbedingt diese Chefstable-Folge an, Christina Tosi von der Milk Bar. Grossartig, die wirst du jetzt verzehren? Ja, die werde ich jetzt verzehren. Und wir machen uns noch einen schönen Abend und morgen geht's weiter, wir sind noch ein paar Tage in New York, wir haben noch viel vor uns, Hamilton natürlich ganz gross noch.
Comedy-Seller noch ein paar mal, dann sehen wir auch Improv wieder, wo wir grosse Fans von sind.
Chicago.
Musical Chicago und LM Driver Stück. Es ist wirklich noch viel los.
Ansonsten nächste Woche sind wir wieder zurück.
Genau. Kommt in eine normale Folge, mal gucken.
Mal schauen. Haut rein, macht's gut. Wir schicken liebe Grüße aus New York und wir heben ab. Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.